okay
adjective here
infantine yes
seaworth here abelani
callum
mackey here
love
warden
turcotte
proud
boyd
huff
sullivan
susie
cahill
de silvestro
schmidt
toomey
bouchard
mandeville yeah okay
all right thank you everyone you know we
have uh seven bills in front of us today
and then the plan is executive session
this afternoon after we take a little
break after our last um
the uh i'm going to open the hearing on
house bill 1363.
and recognize representative roy
all of you this morning will have
received
a an email from me if you uh
representative roy early this morning
sent me an amendment
which we don't have out of ols but i
sent to you all via email so if you have
your email access you can look at it if
not we'll try to get copies of that
representative roy thank you welcome
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee i'm here today i'm
representative terry roy rockingham 32
to introduce for your consideration
1363.
um i believe this is my first time in
front of this committee in two
in two terms
so i will introduce the bill the way i
introduce all my bills i don't ask you
to otp my bill i ask you to consider my
bill
it's now your bill you're the subject
matter experts
i submit it for your consideration
this bill originated um from a
constituent and then several
constituents
the reason for the bill is several of
these constituents had signed
non-compete agreements when they were
hired
the
compete agreement did not have any
contingencies about separation other
than if the employee left on their own
however
when an employee is terminated it turns
out they're still locked into this
non-compete agreement so what happened
was unfortunately all things apparently
go back to covet these days
they were given the choice take the vacs
or get terminated they chose not to
which is their right and the employers
are right
however the employee is still holding
them to the non-compete agreement
so what that does is in effect it
sideslim sideslides them for an entire
year with no ability to make money
income or continue they have a gap in
their resume
so i originally wrote the bill um
honestly not knowing what the heck i was
doing i just tried to figure out a way
to do it and i over complicated it
last night i um
discussed it ran it by my wife
as i often do and she's from atlanta and
after i got done reading it to her she
said oh sweetie bless your heart i knew
i was in trouble
um that's that's never a good thing from
a southern woman here
she's a director of human resources at a
billion dollar company
she knows what she's talking about she
said terry you over over thought that
make it simple make it sweet so that's
what i did
this bill as amended if you will adopt
the amendment
the amendment simply says if you are
terminated
the non-compete becomes void unless the
employer wants to pay for your
your um your time in other words when
you sign a non-compete agreement you
agree i'm not going to go to one of your
competitors and take my mind and my
intellectual
property that i've developed or my
skills or knowledge or my sales contacts
with me in her your company
which is legitimate i don't think we
should be getting involved in private
contracts unless it affects the public
in such a way
like this where it actually would freeze
a citizen
from making any more money in their
field
so for example a sales and this is one
of my constituents she's a salesperson
does good business
her employee excuse me her employer
asked her fax she said no thank you they
said okay well
thanks for working for us keep in mind
you can't work for a competitor well
that's all she knows that's her that's
her feel that's our expertise
so for an employer to be able to free
someone out of the employment market for
an entire year
is wrong no matter how you look at it
it's wrong
so
in the interest of the employer
there's a way for them to get out of
that if they want to buy that employee's
loyalty for that entire year
then they should continue to pay it
so the amendment as it's written says
if you're terminated
and they wish to hold you to the
non-compete agreement they have to
continue your pay and benefits for
whatever term the non-compete agreement
was
so if you have a one-year non-compete
agreement
they can terminate you but for that year
they have to buy you
and buy you out and pay you as if you
were still working there
that's your health insurance
and your pay and compensation
or i also put in there that the parties
can renegotiate
the agreement so that the company could
say okay
we'll let you out of it we'll give you a
lump sum there's still the ability for
the private
renegotiation of the deal but at the end
of the day if the employer is not
interested in that
they have to pay it and if the employer
refuses to do that
and the employee is forced to litigate
to get their money or their freedom i've
provided some teeth whereby if they
prevail in court they're entitled to up
to trouble damages and their attorney
fees
um
according to my
my better half an expert most companies
will avoid that and they'll just buy the
employer employee out
but at the end of the day no one should
be frozen by an agreement that they
entered into
that had no contemplation of something
like this happening to them so having
said that i'm open to questions thank
you
thank you for your testimony any
questions for the presenter
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
presenting this bill i was wondering we
had um
a another bill
trying to deal with a very similar
subject in a slightly different way it
was hb 1089
sponsored by representative cofoult have
you
seen that bill i know i have not no but
if there's another bill out there i mean
whatever car drives i'll get into it
all right thank you
any other
questions have a question representative
roy um
since i'm involved with non-competes in
my business
um it's a couple supreme court rulings
in new hampshire over the last five
years it pretty much
made most
of the
most egregious parts of non-competes
illegal
you cannot as i think the judge stated
in his ruling
preclude someone from being able to work
yes you can say they can't go after the
same clients yes you can say you can't
use their intellectual property yes you
can say
you can't take their trade secrets but
you can't stop someone from working
you can't say you can't work with an x
amount of miles or things like that so
i'm interested in
knowing a little more about individuals
and is it your intention
that
if the employer doesn't buy someone out
that it's okay to go after their client
base utilize their intellectual property
uh utilize
prior sales leads or or things like that
because not competes have a lot of stuff
in it absolutely not that you just can't
work absolutely they do
and the intent of the bill is solely
the employment piece intellectual
property remains intellectual property
and i believe there's even u.s supreme
court cases that deal with that um so no
this this would not be and if it looks
that way please let's amend it i do not
want this to make it so that employees
can steal
um intellectual property or anything
client bases that they developed through
their employer or part of their
employment it's simply the work part now
as you said there are some supreme court
cases from new hampshire but they didn't
deal with termination or involuntary
separation to the best of my knowledge
they dealt with people leaving on their
own trying to get work somewhere else so
my sole goal in this is so that
people who are terminated for cause
and regardless of the reason the cause
doesn't have to be coveted
should not be frozen out of work for a
year and so far the court hasn't
addressed that issue so if we need to
fine-tune this i i'm happy to do that i
think that's a good idea to specify
ip and things of that nature don't it's
about the employment itself that they
can work and even if it is for a
competitor because
that is their area of expertise if
someone works
pardon the frogs in my throat if someone
works in sales with a particular product
area
to tell them well you can still work in
sales but you got to go learn this whole
new product area and develop your i mean
it's it's not fair for someone who's
spent their career building that wealth
of knowledge as long as they're not
taking the knowledge that was the
property of their previous employer
would these
cases of individuals who were terminated
for refusal to
be vaccinated
have were they involved with the
healthcare industry
no they were sales um nothing to do with
healthcare one of them was i believe
actually
um beauty products um
so it wasn't healthcare
okay any other questions for the
presenter
xenon thank you very much i appreciate
like to next call peter mcnamara from
good morning
thank you mr chairman and thank you to
the committee my name is peter mckenna
and i'm an attorney with the new
hampshire department of labor
i'm happy to answer any questions but i
wanted to note a few things about hb
that we've noticed here at the
department
there's two things mainly that i did
want to note the first is that the bill
does define what a critical shortage is
but the bill does not appear to define
what it is when a job or skill set is in
high demand so the bill does not appear
to give the department any guidance
when we would make a finding or how we
would make a defining as to when that is
in high demand
it's very straightforward as to how we
would find something
is in critical shortage but we don't
seem to know
how we would make that finding and it
seems a straightforward fix would be to
simply say
if there is a critical shortage then it
is in high demand it would stop any
discretion on our part it would be a
simple and straightforward mechanism for
the second thing that we noticed is also
along the lines of discretion it's the
statute says that the com the
commissioner may suspend non-competes in
such a situation
and again it's not clear to us when or
how that discretion is expected to be
utilized what the standard would be for
the commissioner in terms of deciding
when to utilize that discretion and when
to suspend those non-competes
and again it's up to the committee and
it's up to the legislature in
determining how it wants to give that
discretion but it may make sense to
again say if there is a critical
shortage and if there is a high demand
for that skill set to simply suspend
those non-competes for a period of time
if there is the desire to give the
department of labor some discretion
then imposing a standard on the
commissioner and how that discretion is
utilized might make some sense because
right now the way the bill is written
it just sort of says or it reads that
the commissioner may suspend and it
gives the commissioner discretion and
defining how it may suspend and in how
it finds whether the
job or skill set is in high demand so
those are the points of clarification if
this bill were to go forward that the
department would like to be clarified or
might be helpful to clarify going
forward
um other than that we take no position
on the bill ultimately
and i'm happy to take any questions if
there are any for the department
uh mr mcnamara i'm not sure if you heard
at the beginning of the
hearing
um representative roy has had a complete
rewrite of his bill an amendment i know
you were referring to what's in front of
you and i respect that we'll try to get
you that
copy as soon as possible so you can
opine va uh maybe on via email uh once
you get that and see the
the perspective changes uh that being
easy one for you thank you very much
thank you
mr juve has not put a pink card in but
i'm making them come up anyway
okay
five years ago when representative keith
murphy
in this committee submitted something
that um you must have a non-com if you
have a non-compete you must present it
to the employer before you hire them
um you brought me in front of your hr
committee and i got raked over the coals
for that by the bill
which was seems pretty
pretty minor now so
i knew you probably had something to say
all right
how's that uh for the record my name is
dave giuve i'm a senior vice president
with the business and industry
association
and uh for those of you that i know on
on a more personal level i am pleased to
say i'm no longer interim president we
have a new president at the bia so
that's a responsibility i'm happy to be
free from
um
miss chair i'm glad you clarified um
what is happening right now because i
was sitting in the back looking at 363
going this this seems
uh
it seems like we're talking about a
different bill so i will quickly adjust
and i remember that situation five years
ago i do not remember you being raked
over the coals my memory is we treated
you very respectfully no you did you did
i'm
having some fun with you david yes you
did
um i haven't seen the amendment but i
was able to hear the prime sponsors
explanation and just a couple of
concerns i would like to share with the
committee
the first is there are
many companies in new hampshire and
there
is a potential for more many
many other companies to be added to this
list that are under a federal vaccine
mandate
right now
any employer that is receiving medicaid
uh or i think medicare money
is required to have a uh their employees
vaccinated and there are exemptions that
are provided for uh religious
beliefs or medical reasons but
nonetheless the employer is required to
implement that mandate so there's
really no flexibility on their part in
terms of an employee who
chooses that they want to
leave
secondly in
hearing the description of the amendment
it occurs to me that it it would require
this one essentially one year severance
for
um termination but there are many
reasons that employees may be terminated
because of their own behavior
they could be
having repeated uh work-related
infractions they could be threatening uh
other employees they could be stealing
from the company
the list is endless so it seems
inappropriate to require a company to
pay them
essentially for a year of work when
they've been terminated for cause
and then the third
thing i would like to remind you and the
chair already did a great job of this
this whole issue of non-competes was
discussed thoroughly in this committee
and in the house and senate and i think
a um
it was resolved in a way that was both
fair to employers and employees so
this
at the very least would upset a system
that it seems to be working for
everybody so mr chair would be happy to
answer any questions
thank you representative vlog
thank you for taking my question thank
you mr chair uh would you believe that
people have been fired over facebook
posts and put with political views
i
i guess i'm willing to believe it i'm
not aware of that uh
in my own experience but would you
believe that employers now are so
strapped for employees that they are
almost doing anything other than
terminating people because they're
having a hard enough time finding uh
people to fill vacant positions without
adding to that problem
oh miss chip i believe both of you
um uh would you believe that's going to
end
um you know we're going to get past that
um i i i do know people that have been
fired over their
their facebook posts
then uh you know
fired for cause terminated for cause
okay you know but when when an employer
is allowed to do that um you know and
then enforce a non-compete agreement uh
i have a real problem with that
presidential cahill and followed by
seaworth maybe
thank you mr chair and thank you mr juve
correct me if i'm
wrong but is not new hampshire an at
technically yes although uh as you and i
both know there are
um
occasions or exceptions to that but in
general yes it is an at-will state
thank you
robert seaworth thank you mr chairman
and thank you for your testimony and i'd
like to draw on your expertise if you if
you can help us
now you're making me nervous
so
um
during the presentation the chairman
brought up well i'm i'm referring to
your comment about how the law seems to
have settled into a good balance right
now the chairman brought up an issue
that i have some concern about that
there are supreme court cases that
dictate
that that limit non-compete agreements
that are not reflected in the law so i'm
wondering if there's a gap between what
the courts would do if it went to court
and what the department of labor is
allowed to do based on the written law
any comments on that certainly thanks
for the question um i should make sure
everyone clearly understands i am not a
lawyer and i'm especially not an
employment law
lawyer although we have many
of those within our membership whose
if that is the case and it seems
reasonable that it might be i might
suggest rather than going through with
this you might want to consider
forming
whether you do it statutorily or not
forming a group to look at
the state of current non-compete
statutes and the impact of of state or
federal supreme court decisions and see
if there is some type of remedy that
that is needed
and we would be happy to participate in
that thank you
representable
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
your testimony
would you
or your organization say that
the
right of an employer
to negotiate with an employee for a
non-compete clause
is an important and valuable right
that that company has
yes i i would say for for
some comp i think we can all agree that
most companies in the state don't have
non-competes but some do and for them it
is
any additional questions
sitting on thank you thank you mr chair
representative love would you turn off
your microphone please i'm sorry thank
you are there any other individuals who
would like to speak on behalf of the
sitting down thank you very much i'll
close the hearing i'm going to turn the
microphone over to vice chairman
seaworth i have to present a bill on
another committee we'll be in five
minutes we'll be um
having the uh 11 11 43
representative sullivan
mr chairman did you intend to include
this bill in the bills to be uh exec
today it's on the list
no i did not
thank you
but i'm going to make you do it just
because you asked me
i said no favors today um no i you know
you
good question all right if i could have
everyone's attention where
we've still got a few seconds before the
hearing starts
before we open the next public hearing
um
i was
some questions came up about what's on
the schedule for executive session later
this afternoon
the chairman did send out an email on
february 4th
some of us may have read and forgotten
some of us may have have missed that so
i wanted to read down the the bill
numbers that were in that email just so
everybody has that and can get i think
ahead he did remind us that he may add
others he may take them off as
circumstances dictate but here is the
list that he sent
hb
1053 hb
and i won't say hb every time
one zero nine four
one one two four
one two five one
all right and with that i made us a bit
late
so uh that
the chairman's mother doesn't give me a
call i will get us started here
and we have
representative mark allegro the prime
sponsor of the bill
good morning mr chairman and good
my name is mark allegro as was just
stated i'm the representative from
comprised of campton the town of campton
and uh
i'm here
i sit on the edna committee
and i hear very frequently when people
come up to testify this is a simple bill
and
i'm sorry but i'm going to lay that one
on you here now this truth this truly is
a simple bill and i'm just going to
talk in two little uh clusters here
um
i'm not here to debate
or really even to make a point of
the
efficacy
or the safety of the vaccines
or even whether they should be called
vaccines
but
it's critical that the people on this
committee and the public understand
some facts about it in order for me to
exp
in order for me to turn off my phone
which i didn't silence
there we go
many of you are familiar with the
cdc
and fda vers
um it is under the auspices of the
department of health and human services
the us department of health and human
services
the the acronym vares
stands for vaccine adverse effects
so
the point here is that people are losing
their jobs
for
requesting exemptions to vaccination
and
i want to explain to you
the efficacy the dangers
and the reason why these people may be
hesitant to be vaccinated
again this is from the vaccine adverse
effects reporting system this is the
national institutes of health
cdc and fda
when we get through with this some of
you may choose
to not believe it but here are the
scientific facts
from the years
there have been 137 deaths
related to vaccine administration
for all current vaccines put together
okay that's an average of little over
four per year this is in the state of
in 2021 we started administering the
covet vaccines
for that one year alone
there were 64 deaths in the state of new
hampshire
that's 16 times
more deaths
on an annual basis
it's more deaths
than all other vaccines combined
or i should say it's it's it's on the
order of the number of deaths for all
vaccines combined for 31 years
just that one
vaccine feel free to interrupt me if you
that doesn't count
hospitalizations permanent disabilities
other injuries like miscarriages
or even what
some physicians are telling patients are
normal reactions
for instance
lymph nodes swollen up to the size of
golf balls
okay
um i have a little bit of background in
immunology
and i'm here to tell you that when your
lymph nodes swell up to the size of golf
balls or you land in the hospital for
some other reason
that's not a normal response to a
vaccination
so um
you know the counter argument to all of
this is that well
compared to the number of deaths that
there might have been
if these people weren't vaccinated it's
a small number and that's true
and here's where i'm going to wrap up
the discussion of this data
that's akin to asking somebody to play
russian roulette
you put in a bullet you spin the chamber
you hold the gun to your head and you
pull the trigger
chances are not big that you're going to
blow your brains out
okay
but
is there anybody in here who wants to
play russian roulette is there anybody
here in this building who would like to
be forced to play russian roulette
i can answer that question we can each
answer it for ourselves
so
the rest of what i have today is
relatively uh brief we last year at
about this time maybe eight nine months
ago
we had a big debate about
vaccines and employment
and
it was a common um
point
made by
our friends on both sides of the aisle
that we can't be telling businesses what
to do
they have to take responsibility they
have to make their own decisions there's
a great deal of merit
but i also would put to you that
in addition to the power to make their
own decisions
the responsibility of making their own
decisions
includes not throwing an
another tax burden on the people of new
you can't take a vaccine
because you've had a heart attack you
don't feel safe doing it or you have a
religious uh exemption request or you
just don't want to
all right
when i would like this bill to say
to businesses is
it's your decision if you want to
release that person
it's your decision
but it's also your responsibility
so now 100 i've been in touch with our
[Music]
department of employment security made
sure that some of these things that i'm
saying because i'm no employment expert
100 of unemployment insurance is paid by
the employer the trouble is is that
these people who were released because
they didn't want to or couldn't take a
vaccine or had
natural immunity is that they don't
receive unemployment insurance
this bill
proposes that employers who choose to
release employees for that reason
make available a severance package
for these employees
well why never mind the misery and truly
inhumanity of dumping somebody without a
job
in this market today where
many businesses choose not to hire you
if you're not vaccinated
but in addition to that
taxpayers often pick up the tab
on other benefits programs like
food support supplemental nutrition
support and so on and so forth
in addition there's a cost to all
taxpayers
at the federal level which includes we
new hampshire citizens
for instance the administration of
unemployment uh of of the unemployment
program paid by excuse me if i don't
know how to pronounce the acronym i'll
spell it out futa it's the federal
unemployment tax
pays for the administration of
unemployment uh benefits in the
individual states if there's more
unemployment there's a higher cost in
administering it
folks that's coming out of your pocket
and my pocket
and the pockets of other people across
the country just as our new hampshire
just as we're paying a federal tax here
in new hampshire
for people in california
to administer these programs
i pointed out that taxpayers often pick
up the tab on food stamps and other
benefits programs in addition
the cost to all taxpayers federal
taxpayers which includes
we new hampshire taxpayers
can be increased due to the well is
increased
for instance the federal government pays
unemployment under specific programs
such as the trade act
i don't have to repeat that the federal
government doesn't have money
the money comes out of our pockets the
taxpayers and the feds can pay up to
fifty percent of extended benefits
during high unemployment
so here's the deal in a nutshell
businesses should
there's a great deal of merit in the
argument that businesses should have the
ability to release employees
who
don't want to or cannot for whatever
reason are not vaccinated
but at the same time uh to cut them
loose in the sea of unemployment with no
support and foist some of that cost on
we the taxpayers is wrong this is a
simple solution
it says businesses go ahead and fire
them but you're gonna have to take the
responsibility
off of the taxpayers shoulders you're
gonna have to provide a a severance
package it can be viewed as a severance
severance package for six months
up to two-thirds of the employees
compensation package
and we've all taken responsibility for
our own actions
the employee
the employer
the taxpayer
and most importantly the new hampshire
house of representatives
with that i'll
be happy to answer any questions and
let's abandon house etiquette be direct
and hard with any of your questions
my career as a researcher and educator
for 40 years that's what i've done is
answer questions i love answering
questions
hit me please
i i would uh
ask the committee to
to
refrain from abandoning etiquette
and uh bend it a little bit just but
we'll ask if anybody has questions
um i'll start with representative
sullivan
thank you mr chairman um thank you for
taking my question thank you for your
testimony in many ways very compelling
um
one of the things that mr juve said in
the last hearing is that
one category of employees that
is hit with the vaccine mandate are
medical
employees and i'm thinking about
our other job back in the county
taking care of our county nursing homes
um those folks have to be vaccinated or
they have to
um be terminated
um you expressed a lot of legitimate
concern about
placing a burden on taxpayers
our county
nursing homes are paid for by tax
dollars and if we have
pay compensation um that comes from tax
uh tax dollars in the county uh how do
you respond to that yeah you're right
and that's a good point and thank you
and if i were going to request or
suggest an amendment for that i would
make provision for government entities
um
well for
for health care
government
owned government-run healthcare entities
if it's a private health care facility
then i think it should fall under this
same the provisions of this bill
but if it's a government entity
then it should uh
the provision should reflect current law
which says that healthcare
help government-run healthcare industry
if i were going to ask or um
ask for or
you know be highly pleased with such a
an amendment
i would point out
um how flush our general fund is right
now in our rainy day fund
and how highly available federal funds
are and i would suggest that some
provision be made for these employees as
well
from county and other government-run
health care facilities but thank you
representative babalani
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question
representative um part c lines 10
through 13.
so the employee gets six months
severance
um goes walks down the street gets hired
by a non-mandated employer
the following week so the previous
employer gets dinged for six months the
employee makes out on the deal has a new
job the following week how do you how do
you rectify that
i do not have the bill in front of me
but that is not the intent of the bill
if
if uh
if an employee or a former employee
finds employment unless that's i'm i
think gosh ols please help me
um the intent of the bill as i expressed
it to ols
was that if an employee finds employment
the problem is solved i'm not looking to
punish businesses i'm not looking to
punish employees or have anybody benefit
uh unnecessarily
somebody comes out
finds a job two weeks later
well the severance package is no longer
in order
did i answer the question is that
thank you follow up
thank you um
first part is right so who would monitor
that the employee is no longer working
would it be the former employer would it
be employment services would it be dol
would it be the actual employee
um
well if i were paying
the fee
i would be monitoring it
uh actually another um
aspect of this bill which i did not
discuss is the idea that
the employees need to file with the
state
a um
you know a plan and a policy
and that policy
could mesh with uh monitoring
employees
built into the severance program
that the company puts out as their
policy
could be a bi-weekly or monthly
report from the employee
confirming that they have not found
additional employment
very much like our unemployment system
now
i mean yeah and this the state as well
could monitor this just as our current
unemployment system is handled thank you
for the question
representative warden thank you thank
you
my questions regarding the uh two-thirds
of the salary
and benefits received but a lot of
people
that are in sales receive bonuses and
commissions
and the way this was written it's my
understanding that those would not be
included because it only refers to
salary is that your intention
well that's correct um
you can't account for
bonuses and um and
commissions
this uh plan as it's written
uh is
somewhat more generous than our regular
unemployment system
which provides a maximum of i think 430
or so uh for unemployed individuals for
up to six months
this uh provides something closer to
reality for that employee
so uh yes it's entirely possible
uh that they're not making their
commissions
but it's something to put food on the
table
representative turcotte
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking the question
would you say that
the policy
statements that you're looking for here
a policy
in your opinion is that something that a
private business
would develop on its own
yes because this isn't state law that
they're
they're uh developing policy on this is
company law
uh and the only difference is that we
want this
policy
to be available to the employee
and
to the state
as well as to potential employees of
that company
so
this isn't uh the situation is not that
the state is going to approve policy
but it's going to be on file and
available as a public record
did i address the central issue
follow-up um
yes
the second part of that question though
goes to
since this would apply to private
employers
and
as we on this committee have said and
you in your opening remarks have said we
tend to not get in between
the private business and their employees
on line seven where it talks it says the
policy at a minimum shell and then it
goes on to in what term i would use
would dictate three
specific items that
the employer must include
would it
my interpretation of that is that we're
dictating policy to
a private business would that be your
intention well um
we do that all the time although we all
like to run around and say that we don't
interfere with
with private businesses we do we require
uh policies and plans regarding uh
occupational safety and health to be
filed
of all businesses
so uh i'm looking at the wording here uh
the policy at a minimum so it's up to
the uh corporation or the company uh the
business permitted employee to opt out
of the medical mandate well that's the
whole central issue here that's they're
already allowed to do that
permit an employer to terminate an
employee that's what we're claiming is
their right
but then to require that employer to put
on record
their policies in making such decisions
in other words if one person comes with
a
it has to be clear why they can say
no to that employee
and yes to this employee
so
[Music]
telling businesses what to do is what we
do here in the legislature
okay it's what we do
360 days a year so i did point out that
this was part of the debate 10 months
ago but i'm not saying that i'm on board
with it
we tell businesses what to do all the
time and we just came off of a two-year
period of telling businesses what to do
at an unprecedented level
so asking them to file you know this
this would be how
how i would say it asking them to file a
policy
that could be made available to
employees potential employees and
it's a minor thing i think
please do one more follow-up
just to be clear i'm not unsympathetic
to where you're trying to go with this
i'm just saying the way that it's
written
actually that does go and dictate
specific things that would apply to a
private employer the other comment that
i will make
so you're aware of w we in this
committee have seen multiple bills that
are all kind of
overlapping like this and i would say
this might fall
partially into that just just for your
information is that a question
would you believe
that's great i gotta remember that
so yeah may i just comment uh to that or
answer that question
um
yeah i i just wanted to set the record
straight that uh
um i don't think it's a powerful
argument that
we shouldn't be telling businesses what
to do
um
or rather
it is a powerful argument except that we
here in state government really don't
adhere to it at all
so this is a uh
i know some of us more than others uh
this is a case where um
you know
i think that the uh the rights of the
individual
have to be placed somewhere up there
with the rights of the businesses
that's that that has been the counter
argument too
to what we're discussing
further questions and i'll come back to
representative avaloni after giving
representative love a chance
thank you mr chair thanks for taking my
question uh
you know there's uh
a lot of questions you know have come up
but uh
uh you won't get an argument out of me
as far as the uh the safety of this
vaccine i've got family members that
have been injured by it friends that
have been injured by it and um
you know there's no recourse
um
uh one thing i would like to ask is that
would you be uh
okay with an amendment uh and it did i
think it would cover a lot of these
bills that uh you know that were getting
hit in every direction with them
to relieve the company of any liability
from an employee coming in saying i
caught covet here and i'm suing you
and
on the other hand
okay
give the liability to the company if
somebody is in
is injured by a mandated vaccine
you know whether it's 5 10 years down
the road if it can be proven that any
vaccine i'm talking um you know if you
mandate it if you force your employee to
get it
you're liable
would you be
would you be okay with an amendment
i would be in amongst um
the bills that uh
representative turcotte was speaking of
i know i don't know if it has
persisted or if it was withdrawn but
i know there was one house bill that
addressed the issue of uh injury due to
mandated vaccine
um
if
this bill now belongs to the committee
and if this committee uh wanted to put
that in i'd be delighted let me address
the other uh side of that coin
um an employee um
this is my bailiwick
and i'm here to tell you in spite of all
the contact tracing and all of this
other business
i'm gonna say this strongly there is
absolutely and utterly
no way
to tell where and when someone caught
the bug this is just scientific fact
all the contact racing in the world
there are times when you could tell when
it's highly unlikely that a person
uh caught the bug at a given event or
place because there's a natural
incubation period but even those very
fuzzy borders
so normally
you know
one to four days later
if you've been exposed you might start
coming down with symptoms
but that can stretch out to
[Music]
days or weeks
so it
is completely and utterly impossible
to tell where and when someone caught
the bug
on the other hand
and three days later uh collapses and is
carted off to the hospital you know we
see it in the news occasionally
this because it's a celebrity you know
this celebrity died eric clapton
couldn't play his guitar for months uh
within days after taking the vaccine the
burden of proof will still need to
remain
with the person filing the complaint
the bill is now the committees i would
support and be very pleased to see a
provision like that put in as an
amendment thank you
thank you
representative vavlani
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative again
line five and employer
are you talking every employer that has
one employee or a thousand employees
just so we're clear every employer
so
chairman so if a mom and pop as it was a
sync with a single employee lays you
know requires a
vaccination because there might be
compromise they're you know and they
want their employee to be
you know
not as much of a risk so the single mom
and pop would be on the hook for six
months of severance prank yeah
this is an opportunity
for citizens and neighbors to work out
problems amongst themselves
uh and they can
tell somebody look you know
oh
we're not gonna mandate you to wear a
mask or we're not gonna mandate you to
keep six feet away or we're gonna change
your duties a little bit i hope this is
okay with you
let them come to a uh an agreement
between employee and employer but
yes
this is an employer
yes their responsibility is the same to
their employee just as if they had 30
employees
thank you
one more follow-up
thank you uh representative warden
brought up a great point about uh
non-salaried employees or bonus or
commissions would you have a look would
you
under section c would you have a look
back period added
for for three months more months that's
a good idea
and actually i i missed
that important point in there i
when the question was raised with me
immediately to my mind came the idea of
employees who are on a salary but also
receive commissions or bonuses or tips
and i didn't understand or hear
the point
that uh some people are on commission
and such a hundred percent
uh yeah thank you that would be a good
solution to that to that matter it would
representative mandeville
thank you mr chairman thank you for uh
providing testimony uh i may be the only
one who struggles with this so forgive
me if that's the case but
the
meaning and extent of the phrase medical
mandates is what i focus on
and for example i wonder if a a business
has a rule that
and it's mandated on employees that they
not come into work if they have a cold
flu or persistent cough
and an employee
thinks well here's a chance to get a
nice severance agreement
by
deciding to come in that's just one
example i don't know what if you could
define for us what the intended
um
uh breadth of
what a medical mandate is on the statute
uh i think the answer to that is
inherent uh in the bill if uh let's take
the example you say which is a good one
uh because people
willing to come in and work themselves
to death with the flu or a cold or
whatever and they can infect uh other
employees or the owners
uh but that's not a terminating medical
mandate an employer
has the right to tell an employee look
you're sick as a dog i don't want you
making everybody else sick go home
right he's not saying you're fired
he's saying go home come back when you
feel better
and i'm putting it rather casually but
this is in fact the point
um
now what could lead to a termination if
that employee says no by gum i'm coming
in and working
it's not a case where the
but
to answer your question more fully and
take in all contingencies
if an employee comes in with a head cold
and the employer says you're fired
then the answer to your question is yes
thank you for the question
are there any other questions
for the sponsor
seeing none thank you very much for
presenting your bill thank you very much
for considering and for taking my
testimony
next up i would like to call peter
mckenna
to represent the department of labor who
thank you to the committee my name is
peter mckenna and i'm an attorney with
the new hampshire department of labor
i'm happy to take any questions that you
have but there are a couple of things
that we did want to note about this bill
this bill would be amending a section of
rsa 275 which would be under the
department of labor statute and it would
fall under the department to enforce
this so there are a couple of questions
or points that we would want to clarify
about the bill if it were to go forward
and be passed
it was mentioned and it is something
that we would want clarified as well
which is the definition of a medical
mandate under the bill
because there are some clarifications as
to what that actually would mean to not
clarify
uh to not comply with a medical mandate
the one that we had a question about
actually would be a drug test to not
comply with a drug test there is a
question as to whether
requiring people to comply with a drug
test as a medical mandate of an employer
and if employees said i'm not taking a
drug test and they were terminated for
refusing to comply with a drug test
have they refused to comply with a
medical mandate and would they then be
entitled to six-month severance under
the bill is currently written
it's unclear to us if they would be and
if we were called to enforce the bill
it's unclear how that would come down
with the bill currently written and so
some clarification going forward if the
bill were to be passed on that point
would be helpful
the second point that we think
clarification would be helpful is in
what the monthly severance pay would
actually be because there's two ways
that we could currently read the monthly
severance pay
let's say that you you have an employee
who made a hundred thousand dollars over
the life of their employment but they
averaged one thousand dollars a month
for their salary you could read
two-thirds of the value of the employees
total compensation two ways you could
say that
one if they were to be their monthly
severance would be sixty six thousand
dollars per month for six months because
that's two thirds of the value of their
total compensation is sixty six thousand
dollars so they would get sixty six
thousand dollars per month for six
months or you could read that as
666 dollars is their two-thirds of their
monthly average wage so that's what they
would get for six months it's unclear
from the way the bill is written so we
would like some clarification on that
point going forward
i think those were the only two points
that we had about enforcement and
clarification if you have any questions
i'd be happy to answer them but those
are the only two points we wanted to
raise
all right thank you for your testimony
are there any questions for the
department
i don't see any thank you very much
thank you next up i'm going to ask paula
minihan
to come up she is representing the new
hampshire hospital association and is
opposed to the bill she has some written
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
paula minihan senior vice president
state government relations for the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all our hospitals in new
hampshire we are opposed to house bill
um
let's see the position um it is our
position that employers have the right
to determine what is best for their
employees and their clients patients and
or patrons while this bill does not
define as stated what a medical mandate
is it could be interpreted to mean and
it sounds like that was the intent of
the sponsor
to require
to mean requiring vaccinations as a
condition of employment
requiring vaccinations of health care
workers from communicable diseases is
not new for hospitals and i think i've
already testified to that in front of
your committee
on another bill hospitals have required
vaccination against several communicable
and deadly diseases such as mumps
measles rubella chickenpox diphtheria
tetanus pertussis
and influenza as a condition of
employment with the same type of medical
and religious exemptions allowed for
covid19
we believe it is absolutely the right
thing to do for the health and safety of
our patients our staff and the citizens
of new hampshire
and the vast majority of hospital staff
have been vaccinated against covid or
have received exemptions and we've heard
from many health care workers who
support the vaccine requirement so i
think that's an important point that
they feel safe and going to work because
people are vaccinated or that is a
requirement
hospitals are private organizations and
have extensive written policies
regarding employment requirements
including vaccination requirements this
bill would require all private employers
to submit their policies to the state
i we believe it's onerous and we
question the authority and
appropriateness of such a mandate on
private employers and why just policies
regarding medical mandates as the bill
states hospitals are regulated as most
private employers by the federal
occupational health and safety
administration
not necessarily by the department of
labor so that's that's a somewhat of a
conflict um we are all also it's
important to note that very very few
individuals have either chosen to leave
employment with a hospital
due to this requirement or have been
relieved of their position however this
bill would cause we believe a perverse
incentive to encourage individuals to
choose to not to comply
with the requirement to be vaccinated
since this would end up re they end up
receiving six months of severance
the bill before you does not um specify
is not specific to covid vaccines which
causes additional concerns and confusion
for employers due to the open-ended
nature of the bill language we also
question why this bill does not have a
fiscal note and after hearing the
testimony of the sponsor it sounds like
it would be
actually pretty extensive
requirements
for the state and
we believe that there is a measurable
financial impact to the state of new
hampshire including
to include
increased litigation and associated
court costs not to mention all the other
reporting etc that
is contemplated
we are opposed to this bill and we urge
the committee to find it in expedient to
legislate happy to answer any questions
thank you for your testimony are there
questions
seeing none thank you again thank you
next i'd like to ask
david giuve representing bia
thank you mr chairman for the record my
name is dave giuve i'm a senior vice
president for public policy with the
business and industry association
which serves as the statewide chamber of
commerce we have approximately 400 plus
employer members with over 80 000
employees throughout the state we are in
opposition to this bill uh a number of
our reasons for opposition have already
been articulated so i won't dwell on
those but i
will
focus on the lack of a definition for
medical mandate because
that's very broad and it could include
things like
mask usage i refer to that specifically
because
if you are an employer that is not under
the federal mandate
very few employers around the state are
implementing covet 19 vaccine mandates
and the reason why
is because they understand that a
certain percentage of their employees
are
vaccine defiant for lack of a better
word they don't want to get the vaccine
and they are concerned about losing what
could be a significant um
uh percentage of their workforce so
i hope this committee understands that
companies in general
around the state are not implementing
coven 19 vaccine requirements unless
they are under a federal
mandate to do so
that's not universal but but the
percentage is is very very small
um
many companies especially those in the
hospitality and travel and tourism area
are implementing mask mandates and for
their employees and we see it all the
time whenever we go to a restaurant or
if we go to a hotel employees are
generally not universally but generally
masked and that's because of a
mandate on the part of the employer does
that qualify under medical mandate i'm
not sure but if it does that would that
would impact a large number of employers
around the state
the other thing that seems to be missing
in this
is the length of employment that the
employee would have under this bill is
written
and an individual could accept
employment
with the understanding that there's a
vaccine mandate that they would have to
comply with if they didn't qualify for a
medical or religious exemption
and then the next day
say you know what
i don't want to comply with that mandate
i'm quitting and now all of a sudden
because of this legislation or this
proposal the employer's on the hook for
for six months of two-thirds salary that
individual could
later in the week accept employment with
another company it's easy to find jobs
right now and do the same thing over
again and over again and over again so
there's already been a discussion about
well how do we track if the employee
the terminated employee gets other
employment and i don't know that there's
any easy answer to that
but please recognize that the way this
is written
it's it's sort of like just opening up a
savings account for individuals
in continuum to to take advantage of
this legislation so one thing i uh the
sponsor said that i strongly agree with
state governments and federal
governments do regulate businesses and
we all understand that which is why it's
really critical
for for this committee to
weigh regulation and what its potential
impact and unforeseen consequences could
be on employers that concludes my
testimony i'd be happy to answer any
questions
thank you very much are there questions
was that a hand or no i did see
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my questions uh
you know i
i believe this whole vaccine and mask
and all it's all fear-based um you know
some people are afraid to catch getting
the virus and they'll get the vaccine
some people are afraid of the vaccine
because they don't want to get blood
clots and and what have you okay uh one
one group sphere is no no more
legitimate than the others
the worker shortage
that we're facing now you hear about it
every day
especially in nursing i mean i should
ask this one uh you know you go to the
hospital and uh there's a long wait in
that emergency room six seven eight
hours uh you know they can't they can't
fill all the beds because they don't
have the nurses to do it um
uh it's it's my belief and would you
believe that you know that this this has
a lot to do with it
nurse nurses are quitting and you want
to find find jobs with with uh you know
other nursing agencies uh we've got a
couple right here in the legislature
that have done it
they're going to find jobs with other
other agencies that don't have a mask i
mean a vaccine mandate um you know this
thing's thrown a monkey wrench
into the whole thing and um
you know uh
i i don't know where the the
the uh
uh
that's an awful lot for what you believe
yeah we could
keep it to questions about the testimony
that we've heard rather than additional
testimony from the committee no okay um
i i guess that would be it you know
should i i can't i can't put the wrap
that our own i'd like to respond if i
could and i'll try and keep it brief
okay thank you um uh
your
um
observation that that this uh pandemic
is being driven by fear on both sides i
think is interesting i've honestly never
thought about it in that way but
um i i guess using myself as an example
uh i which i am vaccinated um and i
you know now that i think about it in
that way yes i it was a fear i wanted i
did not want to get covet as it turned
out i did anyway but my symptoms were
very mild i think in large part to the
fact that i was vaccinated
i think another way of putting that
would be people
and employers
want to do
what
they believe based on
science and cdc recommendations is in
the best interest of their employees
customers and people who come into the
place of business so that's a
you know a different way of looking at
it but but i don't i think what you
suggested is an interesting
way to look at it in terms of
specifically of hospitals because we do
the bia does have many hospital members
um and i think you were correct i think
there is a handful of nurses not very
many because as is the previous is paula
minihan from the hospital association
testified the vast majority of of people
who work in health care nurses
nurse practitioners doctors
are vaccinated i am certain we could
find examples of people who chose not to
and chose to to leave employment because
of that but i think the numbers are
that
regardless of
where you fall on that issue that
doesn't really
impact our our overall objections to the
bill
thank you are there other questions for
i don't see anything thank you very much
for your testimony i have one remaining
card kate horgan who represents the new
hampshire association of counties
in opposition to the bill and providing
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee my name is kate horgan i
serve as the executive director of the
new hampshire association of counties
which is all of your elected and
appointed
officials uh in county government today
i'm here primarily on behalf of your
county nursing home administrators uh
representative sullivan did point out
one of our major concerns was that this
will impact county taxpayers
there is no exemption for
public employers and your county nursing
homes are subject to the federal mandate
i will also point out that
county in the county homes we did a
quick survey about how many people have
chosen to leave because of the mandates
that are coming down no one has been
terminated that includes the two
counties that
implemented the mandate at the end of
november beginning of december last year
and less than one percent of people have
been unable to get vaccinated or get an
exemption that includes a mixture of
population
from our employees including dietary
maintenance and our nursing staff so
we've been able to
work with people to uh find a solution
for them so we don't think this bill is
necessary also it was just pointed out
that there is a workforce shortage in
this state i just want to remind you as
members of your county delegation you
all probably are very much aware that
that nursing shortage was in place well
before the pandemic has the pandemic
made it worse probably but it was it is
not a result of the pandemic we were
already experiencing workforce shortages
um i did also want to just comment uh
because i know there's been some
discussion about whether or not cms
would take
or pull the federal funding
i would just provide the example of
stratfor county in september was fined a
thousand dollars for not reporting the
exact same vaccine
information to cms that they had
reported the week before
no discussion no negotiation here's your
bill pay it
um and i think that is all i have to
offer because everyone else covered
everything but i'm happy to take any
questions that the committee has
thank you very much for your testimony
seeing none thank you again thank you
and that was the last pink card i had if
there was anybody i missed or was
seeing none
i will close the hearing on hb
1143 and turn it back over the chairman
who's doing a much better job of keeping
us on time
uh opening the hearing on house bill
1410 and call the prime sponsor william
representative foster william foster
welcome
thank you mr chairman
i'm here today to introduce house bill
this bill establishes that any private
entity mandating
through access or employment
requirements
the choice in a medical decision for its
employees or customers in new hampshire
for access to goods or services
or employment
shall assume liability for damages that
can be shown to have occurred
to the individual as a result of
it does several things
is it clearly recognizes and
acknowledges an individual's
individual or businesses right to
conduct business
retain employees and provide access to
goods and services as they see fit
it then says that
a private entity maintaining or
to
or mandating a requirement
[Music]
for employment or for access to their
goods and services
uh
that that requirement shall come with
the responsibility and accountability
for any consequences caused by attempted
compliance
as the choice is being made or is being
mandated
and being made by private entities
without representation or consent to the
people of the state
additional burdens shall we
will be laid upon
the
entities and what it basically does is
it grants
standing
um
for the moving party upon showing that
the moving party has suffered any amount
of loss or damage
which may have been caused by their
attempted compliance with the entity's
mandate
so what this does is basically say
wants
desires to fulfill a mandate to get
access to employment or to get access to
goods and services
and
they do so and
are injured by that
that they have the ability to say hey
i've been injured by this and it will
give them standing to then
have their day in court and prove with
the preponderance of evidence
that that it was actually caused by them
complying to that specific individual's
mandate
um
there's been there's a lot
i just sat in on the last bill and
there's there's a lot of questions about
get involved in
setting rules for for businesses in
reality this doesn't even do that
if a business chooses not to have a rule
or a mandate they don't have to worry
about it at all that's their choice
if a business decides to have a rule or
a mandate that
for for employment or for access to
their goods and services all this is
doing is saying that if you choose to
make that decision for another human
being
that you're responsible for any damage
that occurs to the person if they're
trying to comply with it
now there's there's an argument that
i've heard by from many that say well if
the person doesn't want to do it they
can just
not do it not get not work or not you
know not work at that particular
business or not go and um get what
they're they're trying to get from a
particular um you know
vendor or or service provider
but the truth of the matter is
that
what we tend to call rules or or
mandates revolve around coercion of one
sword or another
and coercion though it sounds like a bad
word is something that all of us do all
the time we've been doing it since
kindergarten do the right thing i'll
give you a star do the wrong thing i put
you in the corner
okay
i'm not trying to fight that that's how
our world works that's our penal system
works
what i'm trying to do is say that if
you're making that decision
that you're responsible for damages
caused by that decision and that's what
i'm trying to do with this bill
um
so
i would ask for your support
in this bill
so that we can give people some sort of
ability to say hey i have been damaged
by something that you asked me to do
now the idea that well
they don't have to do that it's true but
if you take an individual
um one of the things i learned in the
military
was that if you torture a person enough
they'll break
everybody breaks
okay
and then i hear another thing all the
time where people say well
everybody has their price
so if we make the the carrot big enough
if we make the the the plus big enough
well i can get people to do that too
so eventually if i make the carrot big
enough or i make the stick
painful enough
the person's going to do what i want
them to do they're going to submit at
some point
all this is saying that is if i'm doing
that
i need to be careful not to harm people
in doing it
that's all all i'm asking is that
we put some laws in place so that
when people are making this
determination and setting these rules
that they put more consideration they
are very careful to make sure that what
they're asking people what they're
asking their employees or other people
so
i ask for your support in this bill and
i'm
willing to take questions on it
representative
followed by representative warden thank
you mr chairman thank you representative
foster
um
could you give me an example
just reading the la starting on 22
where it says a business private
business entity that imposes a medical
mandate
i'm just going to leave employee out for
now on a customer could you give me an
example
of
how or where that would apply in other
words
business a gives puts out a mandate for
their customer and somehow a customer is
uh
damaged
can you give me an example of that
sure um
what this is trying to cover is that
it's very hard to determine what a
person's going to going to submit when
they're going to break what is it what
what good thing or what bad thing is it
that's going to cause them well i need
to keep my job or i really want to be
able to go to these concerts okay
so if someone says hey you can't have
access to this or you can't have a job
here unless you do this okay
what this is going to do is say that if
that person decides well i'm going to go
ahead and do what they ask me
okay
then they end up getting hurt because of
it
that they can at that point say hey i've
been harmed and i i need to be able to
be
um
thank you
yes but uh could you give me draw me in
a specific example
of a private business and a customer
relationship where this would apply give
me an exact
not a broad one but
a customer in our employee relationship
not employee no customer a business and
a customer okay
so
um
you have a business
and it says we require um vaccines you
got to show us your vaccine passport to
gain entrance into our business for
goods and services so
um
someone goes to that business and they
say hey i want to come in here and they
say well you can't because because you
you're not fulfilling this requirement
and they say okay well i really want to
shop here so i'm going to fulfill that
requirement
and they go and fulfill the requirement
and in doing so
then they should be able to say hey i
this will give them standing so they get
their day in court but they're still
going to have to show
that it was that particular businesses
requirement that they were trying to
fulfill and that the
um damage is related directly to that
requirement
so if it's a vaccine passport you'd have
to show a preponderance of evidence that
you were harmed by the vaccine
so all this is doing is really giving
also
representative warden followed by thank
if you looked
if you interpreted this
language
broadly
i could it says that if
somebody
has any damage
that
happened from attempted compliance with
the medical mandate and i wonder if you
share my concern that if that's
interpreted too broadly for example
somebody
might be driving
to the
walgreens drugstore to get
a vaccination let's say if that's
required by the employer
and on the way there he gets in a
traffic accident
because he was trying to comply with
this mandate but it's any damages and
now the employer is responsible for the
car accident medical bills can you see
how it could be interpreted that way
well i do but in order to do that you
would have to prove one
that you were going to that walmart to
fulfill a
mandate that a particular employer or a
particular
uh
company had in order for you to have
that access so you'd have to prove that
that was the case
and then um you would have to prove that
um
it was related directly to that i don't
see that i mean it would take a
preponderance of evidence i don't see
thank you for the question
representative babalani followed by
representative sullivan
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative taking the question can
you define private business entity for
me
a private business entity is any private
company
from one person to a thousand
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
the way i read
i'm not employed anymore so
employee doesn't apply to me but i am a
customer right um
and um let's say that um i go out i'm
like mr gervais i i get the vaccine
because i don't want to get covered
and
but when i get the vaccine
i suffered some sort of damage my wife
was sick for a full day that was damage
um
and uh
the way i read this
it would appear that
at that point i've been damaged by the
vaccine i can now go after every
company for which i'm a customer
that has a vaccine requirement for
you know access
and i can
collect damages from each and every one
of them because i'm a customer at all of
these various companies
can you respond oh sure
um well one you could go after one you
couldn't go after every company
because well because what you're saying
is that
one particular company's mandate is the
one that caused you to get that vaccine
so once you've done one you'd be done
and the other thing is you would have to
prove that
that particular company's mandate's the
one that caused you to
attempt to get the vaccine and then you
would have to prove that the damage that
you suffered was from the vaccine
follow up
i hear what you're saying but i don't
see it in the build language um
can you point out where all of these
requirements for one and done uh for
example is in there it just talks about
a customer and it doesn't say that a
particular company um would
be the
the one thing that motivated me to get
uh vaccinated all it says is if i'm
damaged by the vaccine
i can um collect from any company for
which i'm a customer
um damages
well
thank you for the question i don't see
it that way
but uh and and i do believe that in this
it's a you know it is saying that a
private company okay
um i understand your concern and i would
be you know willing to to amend the
language to to cover that um
but
i honestly i don't see it that way but
i'm willing to make changes if necessary
thank you representative mandeville
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
testimony uh at several points in your
testimony you
used the word
injured or hurt
and yet the
proposed
uh bill
on line 24 for example talks about any
damages
on line 26 talks about any amount of
loss or damage which may have been
caused
i take it from reading the bill that
this
injury-based damage necessarily but
could include any kind of economic
damage
or consequential damage
a
an attempted compliance
with the medical
mandate
did you intend it to be as
broad as that
such that perhaps someone who lost a
business opportunity
could sue for the loss of business
opportunity or did you intend it to be
more limited
to the kind of
damages that occur as a matter of a
medical
thank you for the question um
its intent
was not to be quite that broad in the
way that you just put it um and again
it's something that that i certainly
would be willing to amend i think that
overall its intent is to
make sure that that there is
some recourse for individuals that are
severely injured um
when a company
private entity makes a decision for them
all right thank you
any further questions for the
representative
see none thank you very much
thank you like to call
peter mcnamara and uh pauline paula hand
uh peter peter mcnamara department of
labor we are behind schedule so i
appreciate it if you would be
brief
thank you
thank you mr chairman
my name is peter mckenna and i'm an
attorney with the new hampshire
department of labor
this bill would be amending
chapter 275 so it would fall to the
department of labor to enforce this
and there are a couple of provisions
that are specific to the enforcement
here at labor that i wanted to highlight
because they would be
of concern if we were to enforce this
the first is specific to the question of
damages
under this bill damages would not be
defined and so i want to provide some
context because for the department there
are a couple of
types of damages that we do have
encounters with and that we do enforce
as it relates to workers compensation
because we do deal with workers
compensation
and when a worker is injured there are
two kinds of damages that we do
encounter
obviously one is medical bills we deal
with any kind of medical bills that they
incur and the payments for those
as well as any loss of earnings
potential oh excuse me as well as any
loss of earnings potential but there are
a number of other damages that we don't
ever deal with or calculate
pain and suffering emotional damages
loss of consortium none of those are
ones that we ever deal with or calculate
but under this bill damages is not
defined and so it seems that those would
be encapsulated in this definition and
they would fall to us to enforce
but they're not damages that we
traditionally ever deal with that our
hearing officers ever calculate and so
it's something that just traditionally
doesn't fall to us or that
the statutes ever impose on us
the second is that labor traditionally
and always deals with employers and
employees those are the relationships
that we deal with those are the parties
that we deal with this statute would
inject a third party into that and that
is customers we don't ever deal with
customers that's not something that
labor has dealt with historically
and so that would that would be a third
party that we would now be adjudicating
claims with
um and so seeing that this bill is
really granting standing to deal with a
certain new class of claims
uh it might make sense if we're going to
be imbuing standing for this kind of
claim to put it elsewhere because of the
issues of damages and this new party
given that labor doesn't deal with these
kinds of damages nor this party um if it
were to be put with labor certainly we
take no position and we would find a way
to make it work but i did want to note
that on the damages and on the parties
they would both be unusual in that labor
has not dealt with either of those in
the past
and has been noted in the past and other
bills
don't need to expand on it either but
there is no definition of medical
mandate it can be interpreted very
broadly a limiting definition can be
helpful in enforcement apart from that i
don't have anything to add and would be
happy to take any questions
thank you
representative love
did i hear you uh thank you miss mr uh
chair and thanks for taking my question
did i hear you uh correctly in saying
that the department of labor takes no
done
no position correct we take no position
see no other questions for you thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
paula minihan new hampshire hospital
and miss manahan has a
one of many she's prepared for us this
year
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record paula minihan
senior vice president state government
relations new hampshire hospital
association
we are opposed to house bill 1410
it does require as stated on an employer
to assume liability for any damages that
employee or customer can prove to have
occurred as a result of attempted
compliance with medical mandates um as
has been stated there's some confu
we find this bill confusing we actually
don't believe it's necessary and
it raises a lot of questions and i'll
just rattle off a couple that have
already been actually raised medical
mandates not defined unclear what the
sponsor means by that term but we're
assuming he's referring to the vaccine
requirement
workers comp um already applies as
stated by the department of labor
customer as a condition of access to
good services under new hampshire law
statutes excuse me new hampshire labor
statutes does not make sense to us as
stated by the department of labor
attempted compliance i think
representative
grabbed my question
we ran this by some of our hr directors
and they had that exact same question
attempted compliance if they were
driving to a location to get a vaccine
and they got into an accident what does
that mean that the employer would be
liable um it's unclear but that's the
exact um example that an hr director
came up with there's also federal
programs in place such as the counter
measures injury compensation program to
provide benefits to persons who sustain
serious physical injuries or die as a
result of covid vaccine
this is administered by the federal
health resources and services
administration a division of usda dhhs
i have more but
other examples that hr gave me but
for all these reasons we are opposed to
this bill and we urge you to find this
bill in expedient to legislate happy to
answer any questions
thank you for your testimony any
questions representative seaworth
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
that testimony i want to go back to one
of the things that you said at the
beginning of your testimony was that
this bill is not necessary and i'm
interested in some details on that and
i'll i'll make up an example
um
let's say i i want to go into a hospital
for surgery and
the
the hospital tells me before you do you
have to
get this prescription in preparation for
for coming in
and i don't really want to get it but
that's the condition so i do and i'm
injured
do i now have standing to say
i was injured as a result of something
you did is that part of why you say the
bill isn't necessary well i don't know
that this bill
contemplates that necessarily um
it is
we're imposing a medical mandate on an
employee not on a patient
or a customer
i guess you could consider yourself a
customer i don't consider patients
so
that is um info called informed consent
when you are um
agreeing with your medical provider for
um whatever surgery or whatever service
that is needed you you go through a
informed consent process and that is
part of um
you know medical liability and all that
so that i don't see that really
contemplated here we're talking about
employees um
and again workers comp um laws
i think um cover cover the those
scenarios
i don't know if i've answered your
i don't see additional hands thank you
very much thank you
thank you mr chair i will be brief
because i know you're behind schedule uh
for the record again my name is dave
giuve senior vice president with the
business and industry association we are
here in opposition to this bill there's
been a lot
discussed in uh why it's problematic a
couple of things i would like to
add to that and i actually would like to
focus on the whole customer aspect of
this bill because i think representative
sullivan i believe raised a pretty
interesting point of which
i became aware of this morning i made
reservations at a restaurant
uh for the weekend to take my wife out
and they clearly said
i'm sorry making brownie points for
valentine's day
happy wife happy life
um the restaurant clearly indicated
proof of vaccination will be required
for for entry
uh which is not a problem for us because
we're both vaccinated nonetheless
uh if this bill went into effect um
i could look at that restaurant and any
other restaurant or place of business
that has that requirement and file a
civil lawsuit saying that i was injured
i don't even really have to be injured
to file the lawsuit the company is it
you know maybe completely without merit
but the company still has to defend
themselves so
i think this is a little more than a uh
public policy that would result in a
whole new cottage industry of lawsuits
against employers who are who are trying
to do the right thing
in the face of pandemic so i would ask
that you um i don't know that this bill
is fixable i would recommend that you
kill it thank you mr chair
and welcome
representative mandeville recognized for
a question thank you mr chairman thank
you for testifying um coming back to uh
representative seaworth's excellent
question uh let's say and you you did
mention that your group includes some
hospitals let's say a hospital had a
rule that uh in order to have surgery
you needed to have certain blood work
done and so you went to a place to get
blood work done and they injured you
would your reading of this bill create
an
a legal obligation of the hospital
for the injuries that you had sustained
by virtue of the
blood testing facility
uh i i think your question is a good
illustration of one of the problems with
this bill is that it is so broad almost
anything could apply the prime sponsor
mentioned if you were involved in a
traffic accident on the way to get a
vaccine that would
apply well what if you were ran a red
light and created the accident is the
is the business entity somehow now
responsible for the damage that created
you know we could probably come up with
a thousand different examples
of of whether this bill would or would
not apply but but to me that's one of
love
thank you mr chair thanks for taking my
question uh correct me if i'm wrong
but i believe that an employer has uh no
no right to your uh
say for instance hiv status uh hep c
status and a host of other things
uh
why did they have access to your vaccine
status
well um with respect you you are wrong
for employers who are under the federal
mandate they are obligated to
collect that information
and
keep a record of it of course those
records are confidential the way any
employee information would be held
confidential but employers under uh the
federal vaccine mandates do
have a requirement to collect that
information
follow up
so
vaccine mandates and
um other things uh they contradict each
other's what you're saying
um you know the federal man vaccine
mandate and i guess it's hipaa where you
know you're not entitled to my my
medical background um you know that it
sounds like to me like there's
a different definite contradiction here
and um
uh if that contradiction exists it's
going to take someone far more clever
than i to puzzle it out
thank you
thank you any additional questions for
mr b
seeing none thank you very much thank
you mr additional people any additional
individuals
seeing that i'm closing the hearing and
i'll open the hearing on house bill 1529
fn and
recognize representative love to
thank you mr chair thank you committee
members uh for those of you that don't
know me uh i'm representative david love
i represent rockingham six which is
derry
and uh i uh
i decided to go forward with this this
bill as a as a result of uh
a drag queen
um
story hour they called it
but um
you know i uh after after looking into
it
uh you know i i discovered that
the there was no no uh no background
check done on this uh this individual
and uh and
you know we we did stop it at the at the
taylor library in in derry uh
you know they they decided to go to not
have it uh then they were gonna do it in
their public park and there was an
outrage over that
and uh then they did it a private entity
and um
this uh this individual was was dancing
with kids rubbing butts uh you know just
really going way too far and uh and
there was never a background check done
on them
you know i later found out that a few
years ago in nashua
there was a a drag queen
story hour uh and uh
later to find out that uh you know the
guy was a convicted sex offender and um
you know uh
there's a hole in our law i guess is
what i'm trying to say you know school
bus drivers school teachers school
school administrators uh you know school
volunteers they all have to have to do
anybody working with a child
except for a lot in the library
you know we all received in the email uh
talking about the the cost and the time
concerned uh you know uh the cost uh
i'll i'll hit on that in a little while
but uh you know the time uh i had to go
up to the state police uh one time to uh
to straighten out a background check on
a gun purchase okay and uh
you know while i i ended up getting it
straightened out but uh while i was
there people were there getting
background checks
10 minutes at the bet at the longest was
all it took
okay
ten minutes and i i i think it was ten
dollars at the time
um you know not not a big deal
and uh
you know uh not when we're talking about
uh you know the a lifelong life a
lifetime of misery
for a child that's been molested you
know uh
if i if i conduct indulge into that uh
you know uh
you know i was molested as a child you
know at six years old you know uh
11 12 years old full-blown alcoholic
using drugs uh you know my friends
couldn't hang around with me
uh you know as i got a little older you
know relationships i i couldn't hold on
to anything you know
you know
lost a lot of jobs because of the
drinking and drugging uh you know uh
doing doing some crazy things you know
um
you know eventually getting sober
and then
you know at 60 years old
finally taking a look at this thing you
know and uh you know uh
it was a a long time of suffering
you know a lifetime of suffering and uh
you know for us not not to fill this
hole
you know
to me it'd be wrong you know uh i i feel
very fortunate you know to to be able to
sit here you know that this kid that
went through all that hell and and and
did all that stuff uh gets to sit sit as
a member of the new hampshire state
legislature and try to fix this uh you
know and i i'd hope you'd vote otp on
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions representative of
representative turcotte
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative for taking the question
um
to focus on fingerprints is this
is that analogous to a lot of other
background checks that says uh i'm i'm
unfamiliar with this at all so is that
is that something that's yes exactly
thanks for the question uh after uh
discussing this with the the state
police background check division uh i
found out that the federal background
check
does include fingerprints
and it's cheaper
it's four dollars cheaper uh 25 dollars
for a state and 21 for a federal
i'm sorry representative um warden
followed by c sullivan yes
thank you
thanks for your testimony
my question is on the definition of a
background investigation because in line
four you say the
library shall require a background
investigation and
a criminal history records check which
makes me think that you mean the
background investigation is different
from a criminal
record
and so i'm just wondering what you mean
by background investigations that you
know pat call up their parents or call
call their past employers
uh if you if you feel if you agree with
me that needs further definition
i i guess we could probably wrap that
into into one one or the other i think
they
sullivan
lines uh
28 and 29 on the first page
um
says that the
trustees may require the candidate to
pay the actual cost of
seeing how this includes volunteers
would you see
would you think that that might shut
down the uh
the flow of volunteers to libraries if
they have to actually pay for their own
criminal background check
see i put the word may in there for the
reason of how important is it uh
the library would have to make that
decision um you know as far as you know
having this volunteer
how important is it as far as protecting
i have a question for you representative
uh you go on further off of what
representative warden said
further on towards excuse me in line six
of page one the trustee shall require a
federal records check
would you i don't know what that is
the federal federal records uh check
does does the whole country uh you know
it uh you know does a record check for
every state
if we do just the state police
background check it's for new hampshire
so somebody somebody could have moved
from connecticut and uh you know been a
child sex offender and um
you know that they could slip through
the cracks
you specifically reference the situation
what i guess i'm trying the point i'm
trying to make here is
just because they're a drag queen
and you want a criminal background check
because of that incident or was it this
other incident where there was another
situation where someone was a convicted
sex offender in another situation i just
want to make sure i understand the
correlation just because they're a drag
queen does not make him a sex offender
but neither is a school bus driver
neither is a school volunteer neither is
a teacher okay uh if you're going to be
working with children
you you should be checked out especially
if you're going to be rubbing butts with
them um you know
anyway
all right any other questions
see none thank you very much
you're welcome to sit in your seat but
you understand you can't ask questions
i'm going to call kathy
thrown away from the griffin free public
brownie
g-r-o-w-n-e-y
hi thank you kathy growny from the
griffin-free public
library um i'm here because on behalf of
my town my trustee
we can't hear you okay closer
yeah you don't have a sticker if you
don't want to church you can't hear me
let me know i'll speak up
my name is kathy growny i'm the library
director at the griffin-free public
library in auburn new hampshire and i'm
here because i oppose the bill
we are a small conservative community
of 5600 people
and like
most of new hampshire libraries
we are the community center for our town
i am the only full-time staff member
who did get a background check as policy
so we're not against that and we
understand and are very supportive
of the safety of our community
my concern with hb 1529
is the requirement for library
volunteers to obtain and pay for
background checks
new hampshire citizens are civically
minded and proud of it
they enjoy volunteering their time to
help support and build their communities
one example of this for us is we hold an
annual book sale
consisting of 20 000 items which is 25
percent bigger than the size of our
library
it's held over four days which is made
possible by dozens of community
volunteers these are people that we know
that are patrons of the library who
support their community
they are not random people coming in to
volunteer
the majority of volunteers sign up just
a couple of days in advance
which does not give them enough time to
get these background checks
in addition auburn residents are known
to be extremely frugal and majority of
our volunteers are on fixed incomes they
are proud to volunteer their time
but this bill requires them to pay in
order to volunteer which places an undue
burden on them
and creates a better barrier to their
community involvement
and the result is we won't have
volunteers
and as of one person full-time
i can't run a community center without
my amazing dedicated community members
and volunteers this bill is written has
the unintended consequence of being
detrimental to our operation as a
community center and will have a
negative impact on our community and our
volunteers well-being thank you
thank you have any questions
representative seaworth
paul by callum thank you mr chairman and
thank you for your testimony
um my question is
the
the boundaries of existing state law if
you're familiar with them so if i
volunteer to be a youth coordinator for
your library
does
are there requirements
for the state or from the town
yes so um based on law as i understand
it
you could not volunteer as a youth
coordinator i have a person on staff a
part-time person that works 10 hours a
week they are our children's librarian
and because a volunteer cannot do
something a staff member does they would
never do that so the majority of our
volunteers you know whether they're
moving books or sorting books
they're not alone with kids they're
known to us they are library community
members
thank you uh and
no more questions uh i'll now chair if
there are further questions
thank you for taking my question
um
would you
could you please
explain
the necessary qualifications and
required
education for the term director
sure i have a masters of science degree
from simmons college
plus i have 20 plus years experience
direct experience being a library
director so i have a master's level
degree
in training as well as
so your
master's i'm what i'm asking is not what
your education is
what is the required education that's
the return we have the term director
i can only speak for my library and for
my library it is a master's degree from
an american library association
accredited institution
i'm not familiar with a state law that
requires that okay
follow-up please one more follow-up
um
so
could you
tell me
if there is any reason at all which you
would think
there would be a requirement
for background checks
for anyone
as an employee i'm not talking about
necessarily
um
people who volunteer i'm talking
specifically about an employee of any
kind in a library
i i have no issue and i
as i said our town for full-time
employees does do background checks i'm
not at issue with doing background
checks on employees
um i i think that that is um a
reasonable precaution to take when
someone is employed by the by the town
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you thank you so much
i appreciate it
i believe
representing libraries in new hampshire
you're not on
is that better okay
thank you for that uh instruction so my
name is deborah holdly and i am the
library director of the moultonborough
public library um the population we
serve is about 5 000 however in the
summer we
triple and sometimes quadruple that
amount
there is a significant portion of our
population who are retired and they make
up a large portion of our dedicated
volunteer corps at the library
there is a strong sense of community
pride and philanthropic spirit in
moultonborough
the the library is known for its
community engagement and we have a
strong support for the library one of
the ways that people do show their
support is to volunteer to help with
services programs landscaping and
as our previous speaker our annual book
sale
we rely on these individuals and putting
barriers to volunteer will compromise
the library services we provide
as a small library the process of
federal background checks would be
cumbersome and require significant staff
time to prepare process and review all
the applications for the amount of
volunteers we have
also
due to the nature of some of our
volunteer opportunities the background
checks would not be completed in time
for us to bring them on board especially
those arriving in the summer months and
only staying for the season that is our
busiest time and that's when we need the
most volunteers
so i thank you today for listening to my
concerns and testimony as to why i
oppose house bill 1529
thank you for your testimony are there
questions
seeing none thank you again thank you um
i'll make one comment one of the reasons
we're very eager to make sure the
microphone's picking you up well is all
of these hearings
are on youtube
and they're actually closed captioning
the hearings as well so it's very
important that everybody be clearly
understood for the
ais over at the
google palace
um
next up
i will uh ask denise van zanten and
hopefully i got that right
from the new hampshire library
association speaking in opposition to
get on
ah red light got it thank you my name is
denise manzan i am the current president
of the new hampshire library association
and i'm also the director of the
manchester city library
i do support background checks we've
been doing background checks at the
manchester city library the state checks
on all volunteers and our employees
since i took over as director
however as you know new hampshire
libraries pride themselves on providing
a welcoming and safe environment for our
community members and to do so many of
our libraries already do the state
background check
and all of this guidance falls under our
library board of trustees library board
of trustees make the decision as to what
the hiring practices are going to be and
most of them follow what their town or
city is doing
they had cost and time to administer a
federal background check which i spoke
to my city security manager about and
they take two to three months
where it's one to two weeks of the state
background checks right now and
the cost of the city was more for this
check
but my real concern as the library
association president is most of our
libraries serve populations under 7 500
people so they are very small
very different from manchester
and they rely as we all do on our
neighbors to support many important
services at our libraries in the state
and while the bill allows us to put that
cost onto the employee or the volunteer
i do feel as my colleagues do that this
does impact the good will
and the community spirit in our in our
communities and the support for the
libraries
so i thank you for listening
to me today and for your service to our
state's constituents
thank you very much for that testimony
are there questions representative
turcotte
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
the question i should ask this of the
prime sponsor but i didn't so maybe you
know the answer what's the approximate
cost of a background check
i was told the federal background check
for the city of manchester is 48 dollars
and 50 cents
and that's coming from a previous police
officer who deals with department of
safety regularly so i i don't know
that's what i was told follow-up yeah
just make sure i heard you correctly
48.50 would be for a full-time employee
20 for volunteers thank you
thank you for taking my question so
is it safe to say that you would be in
favor of background checks as long as
they are paid for by the community
i am in favor of the state background
checks the federal background checks are
very labor intensive and require a lot
more work
and i was also told that it does not
cover the whole country because some
states have privacy laws and do not
share that information
again from my city security manager
thank you
further questions
if you can help me understand you said
that city of manchester's library does
have a policy of checks on volunteers
is that
universal
um
or is this so earlier someone mentioned
like the one-day volunteer who stands
outside is it every does it cover
everyone or is there a scope so at my
library um we do background checks state
background checks on all employees and
on our volunteers
so we do have to plan in advance for
certain things
and i do have a lot more staff
and i have a city security manager who
actually takes care of taking the checks
and doing all the processing for me so
i'm not your typical new hampshire
library and our trustees do set the
policies
thank you
any further questions seeing none thank
you very much thank you very much
um next up i have a card from katherine
heck i believe
from
new hampshire municipal association in
good morning committee members my name
is catherine heck from the new hampshire
municipal association and we are here to
oppose this bill as well i don't want to
be redundant in any of the testimony
that you've heard directly from our
public librarians however i did want to
bring forward that many of our member
libraries conduct background checks for
all of their employees full or part-time
and for some of their regular volunteers
that's a standard practice because
they're regular volunteers we do feel
that this bill will hamper a local
library's ability to plan programs for
speakers a one-time speaker perhaps
activities or some of the events that
you heard about in previous testimony in
addition to the cost associated with
that as many volunteers may or may not
be open to paying to have to volunteer
i also want to express that 153 of our
communities in new hampshire have a
population of under 5 000 so that's a
significant number of public libraries
that rely heavily on our
volunteer personnel in order to move
forward their mission and serve their
community so i can take any questions
that you might have
thank you very much any questions
would you as a municipal
representative
see any circumstances under which
you would actually support this and any
i would have to really go back to our
members and and see
what
what we might be able to do to amend
this bill to perhaps accomplish the
sponsor's intent and make sure that our
local libraries can continue to function
so i would have to defer and have input
from our stakeholders sir
follow up follow up
so when you say you would have to go to
your members
um let me divulge my position i am also
a selectmen for the town of unity
we are member organization
does that mean you're going to ask every
municipality would you send a letter to
or a communique or a phone call or
something to the selectmen of the town
of unity to let us know
that you want our input
um i would have to say most likely not
we've taken a position of opposition to
this bill based on our policies that we
already have in place that all of our
members including unity have developed
however we would work with particularly
the libraries to see how we could make
palatable to everybody if that were the
case
thank you for the question
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you i have one remaining card um marcia
mclaughlin
representing nhlta
in opposition position to the bill and
good morning and thank you very much i'm
marcia mclaughlin
i'm here
one as the chair of my
library board of trustees in greenland
at the weeks public library and speaking
today as the president of the new
hampshire library trustees association
in opposition of this bill
and
i very first have to say i'm hoping that
you all will all vote to make this
inexpedient to legislate in its current
form
i'd begin by asking why
i did hear representatives loves
reference to what caused him to draw up
this particular bill
but beyond that i don't know what the
problem is that you are trying to fix
with this particular bill
i'm not going to reiterate the points
that have already been made in any time
of
depth by other people who have spoken in
opposition
most of the libraries in new hampshire
already do the
background checks for their employees
not necessarily for the volunteers
that's on an individual basis the
library trustees have that within their
discretion both on the the background
they've spoken about volunteerism and i
i can only um ditto that that the impact
that would be made on volunteerism by
this bill if you require
the background check one
i can speak personally about hiring a
new library director this past summer
we made and i will refer to that in my
third point we made a conditional office
of employment
to our new director
and it took eight weeks
in order for us to do both the local and
the uh
federal background check i
was very impressed when representative
love referred to a 10 minute
i'd love to know where that was done
that you could get that done but it in
in that it goes to
stated in the bill
that the conditional offer of employment
as i said many
mine is not the only library that has
experienced lengthy delays in being able
to bring staff on board
that
making an offer of employment does not
mean that the person who has been
offered the job can automatically begin
working in our case it was you had to
have the background jet
check completed before we could bring
you on staff which is understandable i
think that that's what you all mr love
is seeking to have happen is that they
don't begin working until you know
um
and having these delays as i said in our
case it really put a very uh
deep hardship on our staff again we're a
small community
four thousand people we have seven
library employees only two full-time and
and um five part-time so we were short
one full-time fully vested
employee for that
actually from june through the end of
september
so i just go back to my my original
question which is why
what are we trying to fix that that that
exists
i'd be happy to take any questions
thank you very much for your testimony
are there questions
seeing none thank you again thank you
very much that was the last card i had
was there anybody else who was planning
to testify
i don't see any so i'll once again turn
it's actually my fault and then i pass
it on to you i know what i'm doing i
have air i have errands show up just
looking for me so i can walk out
and call representative brody the shanes
to
uh thank you mr chairman and thank you
to the committee for letting me
introduce house bill 1508 prohibiting
the discharge of volunteer firefighters
or volunteer emergency medical
technicians from other employment
house bill 1508 is a bipartisan bill
that protects an employee that protects
an employee from districts that
prohibits an employer from discharging
or disciplining an employee who is a
volunteer firefighter emergency medical
technician whose failure to report for
work was due to the employee responding
to an emergency the bill was formulated
with the office of legislative services
using language from maine's and
massachusetts laws that protect
volunteer firefighters and emts who are
late to their day jobs because of an
emergency call bill was requested by a
constituent who is a volunteer
firefighter the constituent explained to
me that the recruitment of volunteer
firefighters has been extremely
difficult for many of new hampshire's
communities especially in rural areas
one concern many potential recruits
raise is possible conflicts with their
work hours they have a concern that if
they get called if they're on a call you
know there's specific times where these
folks can be taught called in and that
if they take those specific times to be
called in that um if an emergency lasts
longer than anticipated it makes so then
they uh you know go past that amount of
allotted call time where they kind of
work and balance out their work schedule
that they could end up being late and
that could lead to discipline or
being passed on future
opportunities at their current place of
work like promotions or raises
um
so this is a it's a huge concern for uh
for folks who want to be involved want
to help their communities want to serve
their communities but feel as if that it
would conflict with their professional
work and their their future
economic opportunities 1508 is also a
public safety bill with a shortage of
volunteer firefighters
part-time or volunteer emts across the
state especially in rural areas doing
anything we can do to help recruit and
retain vital public safety
public seat oh wow hello
oh
yeah i guess i'm cursed i don't know
can yeah can you hear me
okay we'll go with this for now then
um where was i
it's essential for all of us to have
these public safety workers and these
hello
hello oh i can't oh there we go look at
all right i'll i'll i'm going to repeat
my last point in case the people in line
couldn't hear me so um
it's a public safety bill uh these folks
they're it's important that we retain
and recruit volunteer firefighters
especially with the shortage that we
have in a number of communities across
the state
it's essential for our safety and it's
essential to protect people's lives and
property with life without them life
would be much much more difficult should
also note the new hampshire fire chiefs
association is supportive of this
legislation they recognize how the bill
will improve recruitment and public
safety in their communities well lastly
comment on the fiscal note in a very
roundabout way the fiscal note
essentially says the cost of the
taxpayers is next to zero there may be
some cost for litigation in the court
system but that seemed to be
um the only feasible increase explained
in the fiscal note i think the new
hampshire
um municipal association or some other
organization might have mentioned or
maybe towns or something that they would
have to work people's schedules around
and that might have some perceived cost
because a lot of public employees are
also volunteer firefighters but i think
that's a cost that they would probably
be able to easily incur so
with that i will take any questions on
thank you for taking my question um
as as i read this um it appears that the
only
um instance where an employee would be
protected would be in showing up late
um it doesn't appear unless i'm reading
it incorrectly that if someone left work
in the middle of a shift in order to
respond to a emergency or if they left
early um before their shift was over uh
does not appear that they will be
protected in that instance is that
correct
um to my understanding where the bill is
written correct they also need to get a
note from a fire chief so from the fire
chief that they serve under to show that
you know that they actually um that they
actually were being called that they're
coming back from a duty call the reason
why we didn't do it so then it was um
they were leaving the middle of their
work shift was because there's kind of
an expectation where when you choose
your shifts that you're on duty right
that you can be called in that you would
work that around your work schedule how
it currently exists
so we didn't want to be too stringent on
employers to make it so that people were
scheduling full eight-hour work days and
saying well i'm on call and you know if
i have to leave for theoretically you
know three hours of that call or four
hours of sorry of my you know day shift
that you know you're you're just gonna
have to deal with it and try to find
other help that would seem a little bit
too stringent when there's a labor
shortage for everyone so the idea was
just to try to make it so there's some
basic protections for folks who have the
uncontrollable thing where they're in
the last hour of their kind of their
duty shift that they're called to and
they end up you know having to do a
two-hour call and they're an hour late
for work that there's no kind of
repercussions because they were doing
something that's important for keeping
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
introducing your bill
my question is to clarify the language
says no employer do you mean that of any
size down to the employer of a single
employee
uh which line is that uh five
line five thank you oh the very first
line thank you okay no employer yeah i
mean i think the way employers written
into the bill to my understanding is
employers anyone who's employed so i
think that would be anyone who you know
they have a w-2 with any business
whether it's the state government county
government local government or any other
representative mandeville followed by
representative warden
thank you mr chairman
thank you representative for the
testimony i i was going to ask the
question that representative sullivan
did about the distinction um
and i and your answer was quite clear
i'd refer though to the methodologies
methodology section which talks about
the need to leave work in addition to
failure report work that's just the
methodology but if you do look then at
the bill text itself
in the first line of section two
in the definition of responding to an
emergency it means responding to
leaving work to respond to and that
still gave me a little bit of confusion
about the distinction between
um
not turning up because you were on a
call
or leaving because one occurred when you
were at work could you
just clarify that i beg your pardon what
line are you talking about i'm sorry uh
the first line of um
section two
okay yep i see that section two yeah i
think actually i think i'm mistaken
there was a couple of um editions of
this build that we had written and um
i think my my memory served me
incorrectly i was operating um and i
introduced a different version that i
had written over the summer i think
you're correct though that um this bill
would include also responding to
emergencies while someone's on the job
thank you and thanks for bringing this
bill to us
question on
line
you said that somebody's a volunteer
unless he or she has worked
975 hours in the last six months
is that an arbitrary figure you came up
with or is it consistent with other
statute or labor law
and how did you get that number i think
um if i'm not mistaken it's i can't
remember which statute but it's based on
the statute from other states from one
of our neighboring states either maine
or massachusetts
um
uh the fire chiefs association had no
opposition to the way that was written
in their understanding but i would be
open to an amendment if it doesn't make
sense with our current state laws with
president of warden what were you
referring to
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you
um i too have a question on 21 and 22
975 hours over a preceding six-month
period would make them a full-time um
classify them as full-time position
yeah i mean i think that's why it says
but shall not include any person to
receive compensation for over nine like
it's not including those people so if
someone's worked
so 974 hours they would be covered under
this section
the way it's written currently yes
correct and one last question mr
chairman follow up um thank you line 18
to 19 where the emergency occurs during
a period other than normal working hours
of the employee
again comes to into the fact that are we
looking to have them be
able to leave their job be late to their
job leave their job early
because it doesn't
it looks like they can do anything they
want as a volunteer firefighter with
their full-time position somewhere else
i just want to make sure that we're
clear clarifying that for the employees
that would be reading this
yeah i mean um i think i would be
definitely open to an amendment where um
there could be some changes to section
two because i can see that as a sticking
point especially to remember many
private employers
right but um let me just read those
lines again you said 18 and 19
yeah i can definitely see the
discrepancy there with um the overall
intent of the bill so i'd be open to an
thank you mr chair thank you for the
testimony the question i have is i i
beneficial to recruitment
but could you tell me on a say an
annualized basis in the state of new
hampshire
how many firefighters or medical techs
have been discharged
or received disciplinary action by an
employer
no because we don't collect any data on
thank you
fault
are you aware of any situations where
this has actually occurred
i'm not aware of any specific examples
however i have um i spoke to this
specific firefighter who then introduced
me to some other folks that he had tried
to recruit who raised this concern as to
a reason why they didn't decide to
volunteer right they had busy work
schedules that they were worried as if
um if they were late to work that that
would end up creating disciplinary
actions at their workplace whether or
not those were you know legitimate
concerns that they had that's a you know
that's something that i could say would
maybe be up for debate but it was a
concern for volunteer firefighters well
potential recruits who decided that they
didn't want to become volunteer
firefighters
thank you mr chairman uh can you hear me
yes
um
thank you for taking uh my question
uh discipli uh if an employer
chose to not pay the employee for the
time that they were
missing because of a fire or
whatever
would that be considered disciplinary
action
say for example
it was a fire all night and the employee
called in sick for the day
would the employer
be disciplining them if they chose not
to pay them for that particular shift
in my interpretation no when i and the
way the bills were written um
no
it would just be not compensating
someone for work that they didn't do
because they didn't show up to work and
obviously it was extenuating
circumstances but if they don't you know
work and put in that labor then i don't
see how an employer has an obligation to
pay someone based on you know depending
on how the contract is structured and
everything okay
thank you
sullivan
thank you again mr chairman um if in
line
15 and 16
if the phrase leaving work to respond to
was stricken from that
um
would that
with the uh bill without that phrase
still um
uh to my understanding yes i think that
was the language that um some of us had
discussed previously about adding to
make it more expanded when we were kind
of discussing myself and the co-sponsors
of what we wanted the scope of this bill
to be i think this edition right now
which you know shame on me for uh for
you know bringing forward a um
uh for introducing something that i
didn't entirely um understand its full
intent but um we wanted it so then it
on a call and they were late to work
there wouldn't be a punishment and we
talked about possibly having it so then
if they were at work and they were on
call and they were brought out of work
we felt as if that might be too
stringent on to employers who already
have a a you know a shortage of labor
right now so we thought it would be a
good balance um to try to make it so
than people who are late to work that
they're not punished and that they can
you know feasibly work their schedules
around their current work schedule as
many volunteer firefighters do
i think there's merit to how it's
currently written but i also think that
there's more drawbacks how it's
currently written so i would be more
than open to an amendment to striking
out
the language on lines 15 and 16 leaving
follow-up yeah i think i think the or i
don't know if it would be um
necessary maybe the war would still be
necessary but i see what you're saying
representative i would be opening to
strike we'll leave it to all us
um but um i i guess the the reason for
suggesting that is it seems
it seems inconsistent because at first
it says at the commencement of a shift
and then it says or leaving work so i
just we either need to adjust it one way
or the other in order to make it work
yeah no i'd agree with that and also
changing the uh language as
representative avalani i'm greatly
mentioned how we decide uh you know how
long someone has been rendered in the
capacity and everything i think that
would be a good um clarification too so
then you know someone who's worked 974
hours is an um you know
at a certain point there should be a
more a better line that might be drawn
that's better for this state for
understanding who can benefit from this
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative senators again um section
4 27-29
this is protective legislation that is
under the purview of the department of
labor and you're taking it out and
sending it to superior court instead of
department of labor
i can't cite any specific one that i
have right now i can try to get back to
you with that though but if you think
it's better on the department of labor i
would you know
i would agree with your judgment you've
served on the labor committee for a long
time so i think if you think an
amendment should be made so then it's
under the labor uh
you know the division of labor i think
that would make sense
are there any other questions for the
representative
i have
they have not
mr mckenna would you please approach
as as the judge would say please
good morning i'm peter mckenna from the
new hampshire department of labor i
believe there are some questions for you
thank you mr chairman um 27 28 29 of the
bill
it seems to be a sticking point for me
taking a protective legislation under
dol and putting it in sending it over to
superior court
would you guys find that troublesome
so it
certainly there are times in which there
are dual causes of action in our statute
there are times in which
claimants can choose to either take
things to a forum within the deep within
the department thank you or they can
either send things to the department or
they can choose to go to superior court
i'm not aware if there are any under
this particular subheading but there are
times in which people can make a choice
as to where they want to go in a forum
i'm looking at the line in which you're
describing
and could you give me the line again
if you don't have numbers on yours oh i
see i do see the numbers yes sorry uh
chairman
yes and so interpreting this um there
are
two things that could be done looking at
this
reading this they could go to superior
go forward with this action but seeing
that it's under 275 the department could
also issue a warning letter to this
employer if they chose to go forward
with if they took disciplinary action
and
that warning letter would instruct the
employer that they would have 30 days to
correct that action and if they chose
not if they did not correct that action
within 30 days we could seek a civil
penalty of 2500 that's what the
department would be able to do on its
own or this claim it could go forward
under superior court under this law but
the department on its own would be able
to go forward with the penalty provision
which is the catch-all provision under
273-11
but under this it would provide its own
cause of action
which does exist in some places under
the law but i wouldn't implicate the
department i don't read this as the
as the department would be the one
litigating this it's unclear to me if
the department would be the one
litigating this or if this simply
provides a cause of action for the
claimant to go forward against their
employer
correct that was my follow-up mr
chairman yes that was my question as
well is this going to go strictly the
superior court is the department of
labor under protective clause is going
to be able to adjudicate this before it
goes to superior court and
the one year um
isn't there a limit a limited amount of
time where an employee can file
agreements with an employer with dol i
mean
so it depends on what they would be
filing with the department in this case
in this case the department couldn't
restore someone to their position if
they were terminated the department
wouldn't have the ability to do that all
we could do would be to penalize the
employer and we could warn the employer
so we could say
you have 30 days to correct it or we
could penalize you with a 2500 fine so
through that mechanism they could
correct it by restoring the person to
their position within those 30 days but
if they chose not to do that all we as
the department would be able to do would
be to issue the fine we actually don't
have a mechanism where we could order
them to restore them to the position
so if they chose to come to us and try
to get us to do something under this law
all we would be able to do would be to
get that fine give them the warning
first and then get that fine if they
actually wanted reinstatement i think
they would have to circumvent that
process and and go straight to superior
court under this provision so
in that way it
it's sort of a strange fit to be under
the labor laws in that regard but it's
not i don't believe that it's
completely
i believe there are other provisions
under the labor statute and which
provide sort of dual causes of action
that a person can
pursue i think that there are provisions
of the wage claim statute that also
allow people to pursue a couple of
different tracks that they can go under
and one last follow-up mr chairman
and that already exists without adding
language to this you can go to superior
court anyways if you've been agreed by a
former employer
so that way there wouldn't be a dual
edge to this you're going to get a fine
from dol and then you're also going to
have to get
follow-up from
the court system judicial system
specific to an emergency responder being
fired from correct
however this is worded
i don't know specific to this in a
situation like this i don't know what
the cause of action the existing cause
of action would be
in terms of if they could go to superior
court right now and get reinstated i
just don't know what the law on that is
existing
thank you thank you mr chairman for your
announcements
thank you mr chairman following up on
the same uh line of thinking
um
as i would read this um if i was a lay
person
i i might assume that the only um
recourse is in superior court um would
it be helpful to add some language
indicating that you know you went into
detail about how you start with the
department of labor
and then perhaps to the superior court
or you might do both because basically
you want the department of labor to
correct the problem with the employer
but you want the superior court to
reinstate you to your uh former position
um
it seemed would you agree that we might
need some additional language there to
clarify the
um
who's in charge of what
certainly i think if i think depending
on what you wanted the department to be
able to do there would need to be some
more clarity if you wanted their the
department to be the sort of the first
forum to go to before you went to the
superior court next i think there needs
to be some additional clarity and there
would need to be some further
empowerment of the department to
actually be able to order to be
reinstated to the position because right
now the department doesn't have that
power we we just don't have the
authority to order that reinstatement
right now if this law were to be passed
as such and we were to learn of a
situation like this
all we would be able to do would be to
send that warning letter that they have
30 days to correct and then to issue the
penalty and and obviously that wouldn't
be very satisfying i think to someone
who lost their position
i expect and then they would want to go
to superior court if they wanted
something more than just us issuing the
warning letter and the penalty so if
there was some other
track that was envisioned it could be to
make the department of labor the first
stop and to have a more full hearing on
the issue
where the claimant could actually bring
the claim that's one option have us be
the forum where that was heard and
empower the department to
actually reinstate the position and then
have the appeal to that peering be the
superior court or you could create two
tracks you could say one you could have
the hearing of the department of labor
and empower the department although i
think there'd be additional language
needed to actually reinstate or they
could go to the superior court straight
from the beginning i think those that
would be another way to write it
but our present read of the bill is that
we certainly wouldn't have the authority
as presently written to imp reinstate
someone to their position if they lost
it
and all we currently could do would be
that warning
and that penalty but right now as
reading they could circumvent us
entirely and just go straight to
superior court is how we would read it
now
representative sullivan followed by
representative cahill
are there areas where you do have the
power to reinstate
and i'm not talking about this bill i'm
talking about in other parts of uh the
statute does the department ever have
the ability to reinstate an employee to
going through things in my head now but
off top of my head i don't believe that
we do i think it is wage it is
restoring wages but no i'm not aware of
any ability that we have to actually
restore someone to their job it is
awarding wages and issuing penalties but
no i don't believe we have that power
representative cahill
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
mckenna um i'm sympathetic to the bill
but i wonder if this is sort of like an
accommodation
where an employer
is obligated might feel that they're
obligated to
come to do it if they can but if it
comes too much of an issue
then where do they draw the line on
how many how many fires or events you
know at what frequency
is not no longer manageable for their
business
and so i think that is
i think
a reading of what the bill i think is
attempting to strike
the balance that the bill is attempting
to strike
um
and i think if it came to us for
and i think if we were
brought into this i think that would be
the read that we would attempt to make
if we were
made aware of this and were attempting
to decide if it were appropriate to
issue that warning letter and attempt to
eventually pursue a fine i think that's
how we would attempt to interpret this
and if that was
the violation that were committed um
that's how we would attempt to read this
and see if that was the violation that
was committed
i don't see any more questions so
thank you very much thank you
is there anyone else who would like to
testify
representative mandeville a point of
order mr chairman could i request that
the primary sponsor
come back up just for a moment
yes of course
approach the bench
and as a matter of full disclosure i
should mention that i'm a um
an officer in the harrisville volunteer
fire company
representative de chase thank you for
coming back i we've been talking about
the possibility of an amendment
i wonder if i could encourage you with
the other sponsors of this bill and any
input you've received from the new
hampshire chiefs association
to think about and
clarify one way or the other as between
a sort of
start of shift only or
something more broadly than that because
this isn't just about recruitment this
is also about
the kind of service that small rural
towns get
from
people who are employed and
it isn't just whether they take a job or
not or get a job or not it's whether
they
are able to come at all
and so if
your group would give some thought to
that and provide the committee with
input on that question i for one would
appreciate it
yeah thank you so much for the question
with with every bill that you know i
bring forward in front of committee i
take notes and i write down the exact
request that the committee has made and
so i think everyone here has brought up
a number of you know concerns and i was
already planning on drafting an
amendment and giving it to your
researcher and having them uh you know
submit it to the committee for you guys
as consideration as a place to start i
do that with every bill that i kind of
bring forward to a committee because it
should be more on my responsibility to
fix the problems that i made than the
committee to fix my problems so that's
how i always look at it and i hope
committees appreciate that but yeah i
have some notes here and based on the
feedback i'll have ols draft up
something i'll try to get something to
you guys before friday
any other questions for the
representative
thank you very very much does anyone
else want to speak in for or against
this bill
seeing that i'm closing the hearing
we will be back at one o'clock enjoy
your lunch i'd like to see the
republican members of the committee down
well
actually
okay
you know we don't want to tell you what
to do in your own time but anything that
you
ladies and gentlemen everyone's
attention please we're gonna get started
my mom called she said she's not waiting
anymore get going
um
there's been a lot of moving parts today
guys
um we are not gonna have an executive
session this afternoon
all right
um but um
which irritates josh and i greatly
because we wanted to get a few things
done
so we're gonna hear our bills and then i
have a bunch of announcements about some
other
meeting dates i was hoping to be ahead
of ourselves but now with a session
house session next week
vacation weeks and everything else we're
getting kind of find ourselves um in a
crunch
so
we'll talk about that briefly but i just
wanted anyone to know if they're waiting
for an executive session this afternoon
it's not going to happen
like to open this session on house bill
14 fn
call representative
cahill to introduce his bill
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
i am representative michael cahill from
rockingham 17 representing the towns of
newfields in newmarket
and i'm here today with a bill which
i believe addresses a problem that's
been ongoing
and uh
yes with uh hb 1514 fn i hope to resolve
an issue that needs leads to disputes
over what happens with unused
time when on with employment ends
i have a history here of several years
of claims filed with the state
department of labor
uh 24 percent of them in 2018
were related to this issue
in 2019 there was 26 percent of the
claims 2021
we shut up a bit in in 20 where there
were 42
of the claims involving this issue
and it's mostly because people
believe that what's earned what's on
their pay stub belongs to them
and this is something that i understand
in the policy and the practice of the of
the employer
sets the tone it determines that but
there are exceptions i think to where we
all we all might agree
that
that the employer the employee has
earned and should retain the time should
be paid for it
i've cited the case where several
employees
lost their earned time when the business
was sold
uh this was a uh
assisted living center people weren't
making a lot of money but the employer's
policy said accrued vacation is not paid
a termination and they made no no
provision for their hours to be
transferred to the new company where
they continued to work in the same
positions that they had done before
the prior owner might have
paid them or might have transferred the
liability that didn't happen this was
beyond the control of these employees
who each lost a few hundred dollars
uh in another case an employee lost
three weeks when laid off obviously
without notice you don't get people
noticed i'm going to lay you off two
months from now
the employer's policy required that two
weeks advance notice was was needed when
requesting time off and that was of
course impossible under these
circumstances
you earn the time it's on your pay stub
a layoff happens nobody knows when it's
going to happen it happens to you and
now instead of having a job
uh you're collecting unemployment
so this is those are the two examples
the other situation is where
uh and i i had to credit or former
member representative nunez
who uh
gave me this information suggestion
leaving the employee leaves in good
standing
that is they've given notice and they
work their notice and maybe provide some
assistance with training their new hire
they leave amicable you know that's to
be encouraged
so when that happens i think it's
reasonable that you would pay them say
to the person well i i guess you could
have taken the two weeks and just left
me in the lurch with
very little notice but instead you did
the right thing by by the company and
for yourself
and i wouldn't want you to forfeit that
which you've earned because you've
really done the right thing
so
that's my testimony
and i also have a letter here i believe
you've all received this this is from
the
wendy hunt of the
greater nashua chamber of commerce which
has i believe she said 400 members at
first glance they saw the bill as it was
it was described
saying that the vacation vacation pay
must be must be paid
but upon learning of the nuances what
was covered and what wasn't covered how
it doesn't apply to
businesses with less than 15 people
employees our user to lose it is not
touched here
the
ms hunt has written a letter saying that
they now endorse the bill and i support
it and that's that's the sort of thing i
think many employers in this state would
do
knowing that it doesn't it doesn't
warrant them to pay someone who's
wronged the company in some way
embezzled
or done harm to it only those who have
either determination not not beyond
their control
or have as it was stated here left
left in good standing
i think that's a healthy situation to
have
i'll be glad to take any questions
thank you any questions to the
representative
representative mandeville
thank you mr chairman uh so in the
context of a change of uh business
ownership and having this impact uh
do you have any
um
ideas about how it
has has worked or would work differently
or better
thank you for the question
representative uh in fact i'm aware of
several instances where it has been
i once worked for a company that was
acquired by another company
which instead inquired two companies at
once
and in neither instance was was the
vacation time or any benefit changed it
carried over under the new ownership
uh
i i threw this acquisition i also met my
my future wife so there was good deal
all the way around
and uh hi dear
and uh
and when she stayed with the company and
it was sold twice more and the last time
that you had to reapply for her job and
in every case
the vacation was not gone it extended
and that's the right way to do it i
believe
any additional questions represent
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative cahill um
on line six through eight could you
well again i think the
the uh the employer has the policy and
communicates it
and
it's you know it's often explained as to
how how much time you'll earn and how
you can how you can ask a request for it
and when it will be used and if there's
i think this is rather this is not
unlike how the department already
requires people
employers to track payroll how many
hours you've worked you know it's it's
related to that it's i think this is
something that's maybe even even buried
down in the rules and could come up a
bit in the statute like we often like to
do
um
so this is i think this is how many
companies that that provide uh vacations
are in time off or pto i believe this is
how they how they operate currently
so it's not really uh
perhaps a new requirement if you already
have vacation time have a process
and if you don't it seemed like it would
be a sensible thing to do
thank you mr chairman um in the absence
of an accrual system earned time shall
be paid on a pro-rated basis can you
explain if the company
has
less than
say 15 say coupling has 15 employees as
written and if they don't have an
accrual system you just walk in your
boss saying a few days off and he
decides to pay you
how would
earn time shall be paid on a prorated
basis if they don't have an accrual
system
well i would think if they if they say
to you that we give you two weeks a year
then you then you uh divide that two
weeks by the by the year it's vice versa
and you would determine how much you
would get if it was being accrued
on you know depending on when when you
when you're
leaving thank you
representative warden thank you
thank you representative gail
the question is regarding the number of
15 or more employees is that number
arbitrary or is that common in new
hampshire
labor statute thank you for the question
mr warden in fact uh that information
was suggested to me by
a woman who operates a business
consulting with small businesses and she
said don't just don't just pick a number
use something that's fairly constant and
well i also talked with
deputy ogden and yes this number 15 is
used in other places although i can't
any other questions representative
cahill
thank you very much thank you michael
you're welcome to uh go back to your
seat but you cannot uh
like to call rudy ogden department of
good afternoon thank you chairman um in
terms of uh the department's position
we've spoken on this bill or bills like
this in the past um i would echo uh the
words of representative cahill to state
that we do see this issue come up quite
frequently and but i mean by come up is
that we get a lot of calls from folks
usually in or around the time of their
separation from employment where they
ask us how this works and what i mean by
that is when folks are considering
leaving employment or are being told
you're leaving employment they
oftentimes will say you know what about
the time that i've my vacation time or
earn time present law 275 435
specifically does clearly indicate
that relative to such benefits if there
are such benefits that they are as
prescribed in the employer's policies or
the employer's practice
so presently what law says is that if an
employer has a use it or lose it policy
or if employer has other certain
conditions uh relative to making that
time become truly earned
that they're able to impose those
conditions so i just point out that that
question comes up quite often as cited
by representative cahill a number of the
wage claims that we see come up do often
involve this as at least an issue
sometimes there's other issues but many
times when folks leave employment and
they file a wage claim they will cite
this as an issue of which they want to
uh
review or have a decision come through
an administrative law hearing in terms
of representative avalani's question
concerning the proration i think to the
extent we had any additional words to
that i would say that we would read that
as saying that yes if you said you
accrue a day a month they would get a
day a month whereas if you said they uh
get two weeks vacation and the person
only works six months they would only be
entitled to that week that's how we
would see it i believe that's how
representative cahill
intended to describe it relative to the
comment on 15 or more
the other part of the law in which we
see that i'll just give an example is
when it talks about safety summary forms
or joint loss management committees that
is something that is triggered when an
employer
meets 15 or more so it is something that
uh i'm not saying 15 is the deciding
factor but that's certainly something
that's leveraged elsewhere as a point in
which an employer is considered perhaps
shifting from very small to something
more than that i'm happy to take any
questions or
answer any questions that come up
is that a question or you're scratching
your head representative sullivan
okay adjusting your glasses
representative seaworth followed by
abelani
thank you mr chairman and thank you
deputy commissioner for helping us out
here
um
i know as you said we've
addressed this bill similar language a
number of times i remember
but not the details that you had
discussed with us
the issue that new hampshire does not
require that paid vacation be offered
and
i think you've shared with us some of
the department's experience with that if
if you remember as i remember maybe you
can help me yeah so to be clear there is
not a requirement in new hampshire that
an employer provide any vacation time
benefits such as vacation annual sick or
things of that nature
through a new hampshire employment law
it's the employer's prerogative the
employer can say i give you two two
weeks a year two days a year or nothing
so what we have when we talk about
275.43 it's not a compulsory obligation
that they have to provide vacation time
it's saying if they provide vacation
time they can actually then further
state
such vacation time becomes due according
any other questions
i have a question rudy um
we have some long-held beliefs in this
committee in the state such that an
employee's tips are owned by the
employee and not the owner that we've
upheld for years one of the things that
i've expressed to representative cahill
over the years with this bill has to do
with not everyone has vacation time or
earned time sometimes they just have a
certain amount of hours do with it what
you wish sick time house
one of the things that does bother me
is the fact that if someone is working
for a company it has for a number of
years and has something provided to them
that says this is what you're going to
have that company gets bought out and
those things go away
what is the department's opinion
when there's a change in ownership
and the new ownership
vacates or changes or alters or takes
away
those benefits that the original owner
has put in place for the employees what
is your what would your standing be on
that so as representative cahill i think
brought up those are oftentimes some of
the worst scenarios because the way the
law reads the
employer who's ceasing operations or
doing the transfer they would hold the
obligation if any and that's what i mean
by that is if i'm an employer and i say
to my folks you have two weeks or six
weeks of time and you're entitled to
that time and you don't lose it if i
sell to a new owner
at time of sale i should make that right
if i don't make that right it is not the
new owner's responsibility to take care
of that the new owner unless as part of
the purchase agreement they agreed to
take on that liability and obligation
they do not hold it we have had cases in
which we have gone after the old
employer and there have actually been
cases where we've gone after the old
employer
and we have had some success but i would
point out that sometimes what happens in
these scenarios is when someone is
vacating a business
and they sell that business and all of
its assets and everything else it then
can be very difficult to try and recoup
time so i don't know if that's answering
chairman infant time but i would say our
view of it is is that there is not in
the law
of equity wand in which to make that
right truly the way the law reads is the
older exiting player should make that
right if they do not it's not the new
employer's obligation
understood but the old employer
the laws are in place that they would
make them
liable if their policy was that the time
remains if if the policy was that the
what i mean by that is if
they essentially would have to have a
policy that was not use it or lose it
they would have to have a policy that
says when you end employment you keep
your time
because then when the company ceases
operation and employment ended all of
those individuals by rights should have
been paid out their time if that doesn't
happen at time of transfer that's where
it becomes a problem because now those
folks lost that time you'd have to go
after the old employer you cannot bring
that claim to the new employer
understood so if it was not a use it or
lose it mechanism in there
whatever form an employee manual
and the old employer
does not provide that you do have the
mechanisms in law right now
to go after that to try to perfect there
have been instances in which we've done
that i would say we've done it tried to
handle it two ways one
at times we've tried to
see if the new owner will do we actually
will sometimes say can we see the how
this was handled was there a transfer of
that obligation if there clearly wasn't
then sometimes there's even been
discussions is there any appetite for
taking that time over and then if
there's not then the new employer is out
of it and then we have pursued the old
employer
and there have been instances in which
we've been able to do wage adjustments
and say okay old employer you sold
you now have this liability for those
unpaid wages but i would point out those
cases are hard because the old business
is actually
oftentimes defunct
uh at that point understood but just
to be
to be clear
the law allows the current law in place
allows you to do that yes you don't need
any amendments to that law right now
because you're doing it and it works
in those circumstances it could work yes
i'd like to i'd like a little more
clarification on that you said should
and could
is it in statute uh that shall nevermind
should and could you know the old
employer shall
pay if if they owed it then it is a
shall i'm just pointing out where
it should is that it's not always
possible to make it actually happen okay
no thank you for the question any
further questions for
the deputy
commissioner saying none thank you very
much
i'd like to call dave duvet followed by
and because mr juve likes to get fun
with me he says i'll try not to ramble
on
oh you're going to hold me to that right
thank you mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is dave
giuve i'm a senior vice president for
the business and industry association
which serves as new hampshire statewide
chamber of commerce i'm here today to
oppose the bill however i would like to
recognize
uh the work of representative cahill and
the many discussions he and i have
shared on this issue
and
say that this propos this year's
proposal
i think is a huge improvement over
previous
uh proposals
having said that
we have some concerns some of which are
practical and some are which are
philosophical i'll start with the
philosophical ones we had discussions
earlier today about
business regulation and the fact that
states and federal governments regulate
business all the time and that's true
and i could say well this is just
another example of that
but to me this is a different type of
regulation this is the state trying to
regulate what employee benefits should
be and that is something that has
traditionally been left to the employer
and is based on a lot of things the
employer's ability to afford the benefit
the necessity of the benefit in order to
attract and retain employees and i think
we can all agree that
all businesses are different and that
there is
little
uh that currently exists in terms of a
standard benefit policy that that
businesses share so
uh representative cahill and i uh just
have a fundamental disagreement about uh
whether it's appropriate for the state
to be designing a one-size-fits-all
benefit for
employers we also have i think an honest
disagreement over whether
the type of time that is being discussed
here whether it's called vacation time
or paid time off or whatever
is compensation he believes and the bill
states that it is compensation
we would argue that it is not it is a
benefit and it's a benefit that is
offered to attract and retain employees
and i'll give you an example of why i
don't consider it compensation
the employer i work for the business in
industry association has
uh
paid vacation benefits that employees
accrue
um based on
the number of years that they've worked
for the association
it also has as a part of that vacation
benefit a use it or lose it policy
meaning whatever days i've accrued if i
have not used those at the end of the
calendar year i lose them i don't get
paid for them i lose them and in fact
there have been many years where i've
not
used my full allotment and i received no
compensation for that so i think it's
difficult to
consider it compensation because to me
it clearly is not
there are parts of this bill that i
don't
have a problem with
lines
four through
ten
i guess i don't know that it needs to be
written into state law but it certainly
is good business practice and i think it
would be an any employer's benefit to do
all both a b and c
so i don't have a strong objection to
that
i also
don't have
a strong objection
to to
certain
situations that representative cahill
and i have discussed in these situations
involved with where an employee
is uh laid off because there's a company
widely off and it's it's a permanent
layoff not a temporary one as we saw
happen frequently during the
pandemic a permanent layoff and the
employee had no idea that this was
coming
no
ability to use accrued vacation time
and then the second one is the one we've
had some conversation on about whether
there's a sale from
one company to another i would again
that may be a situation that the
employee has no
knowledge or ability to act on i would
caution the committee that
creating that benefit you're now getting
into merger and acquisition law which
you may or may not want to get into
but
i can certainly understand from the
employee point of view
that they did not have the ability to to
act on on
their benefit
i
remain
opposed to
the section of this proposal that says
if an employee leaves in good standing
because
again i think it should be up to the
employer to decide whether that benefit
should be paid out if unused it
shouldn't be
a state mandate that employers choose to
do that employers must do so
thank you mr chair i hope i didn't
ramble on too long i'm happy to answer
questions
thank you mr chairman thank you mr duvet
um so you're okay with the 15 employee
employees
uh thank you for the question yeah that
that is a commonly used number here in
the state it's used in a lot of
different areas including discrimination
laws and it
worry to move forward with this proposal
which i don't support but were you to
move forward with it that number of 15
is something that many employers would
recognize
thank you mr chairman um mr gervais
you
for context you referenced philosophical
objections to the legislation and you
said something along the lines of
um
it would be the state determining what
benefits are could you just repeat that
line for my clarification
yes um
the association i represent which is an
employer advocacy group believes it's
inappropriate for the state
to try to
design
benef work benefit programs and that
should be left to the employer
follow-up
thank you
i'm looking at
v-a
an employee who leaves in good standing
whose termination as a result of a
layoff shall be paid for unused earned
time no later than the next regular pay
period
at no point in that sentence do i see
the creation of a new benefit but merely
the state just requiring that benefits
that were previously earned to be paid
where is your disagreement there
my disagreement is that unless the
employer is a stipulated is a part of
the benefit that
uh earned but unused uh time will be
paid out at the time of
termination you're creating a new
benefit
one more follow-up
so
would you then disagree
that
um this is not requiring employees to
create
a unused earned time or to require them
to provide earn time but that it is your
opinion in the position of the bia
that
uh unused earned time being required to
be paid to employees who had previously
earned it
is the establishment of a new benefit
i believe the latter if i followed your
okay
thank you mr chairman um just for
clarification mr duvet um lines 21 22
and 23
um define
vacation time pay time off and earn time
and shall be considered compensation is
that where the issue is
well i have a couple of issues one uh
considering a compensation i've already
addressed we believe it's a benefit and
it is not compensation i do have another
concern that i didn't mention which is
companies call
paid time off a lot of different things
for example my employer
has both vacation time and what we call
personal time and personal time is meant
to be used for
sick days which this bill
alludes to
but it all can also be used if
you're a parent and your child is sick
and has to stay home from school and you
need to stay home
it can be used for other reasons if if
you're
having to move on a certain day and it's
not a weekend and
you can't be at work and move at the
same time it's it's intended for um
situations
involving employees where they need time
away from work that
none of us would normally consider a
vacation
uh and this doesn't address how that
thank you mr chairman um and the
following
line 23 defined sick time or sick day
shall not be considered wages
so the state
the purpose of va would be
defining certain times office
compensation certain time certain words
as
not compensation could you
i agree that that's what it does but i i
guess i would further say again
um
in my case my individual case where i
get personal time
paid time off personal time as a benefit
i can use that if i need to for sick
time or
i am eligible to use it for other
non-vacation related situations that may
come up
and this
proposal doesn't really make it clear
how that will be treated in terms of
should the employee be paid for that
welcome representative schmidt followed
by uh representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
gervais nice to see you again
you used the word benefit as if it were
a gift from the employer
in my estimation it's part of an
employee package that is a contract that
the employee has with the employer
certain things are are yes certain
things are given certain things are
expected also along with that are the
benefits that are listed
they're not
arbitrary they're listed in the employee
contract well they should be
and if they're there then it should be
part of this as well that when you leave
you aren't asking for a gift from your
employer you're asking for them to
fulfill the contract that you had agreed
with them at the very beginning is that
true
i i agree with the general thrust of
your question i disagree
with suggesting that if an employer
offers
a paid
vacation benefit or a paid time benefit
and it doesn't specifically say
that the employee will be paid for
you un
earned but unused time when they leave
that they are somehow
somehow eligible for that absent a
change in state law
we you mentioned a contract i think in
some ways where
it's semantics whether we call it a
benefit or a gift or a contract
but to the extent that you want to
consider it a contract it should
stipulate
exactly what the employee is do is is a
part of their employment
and if it doesn't say that
it doesn't mean that they get it
presented to me
followed by
mandeville and notion
yeah thank you mr chairman
thanks for taking my question
pretty much along uh the same line as as
i've worked at a lot of places and and
one
i'll give the last place i work i was
given a
rules and regulations and and policies
and i read through that and signed it
now
that kind of a
of a policy uh statement can say a lot
of things
one of the things
could be like you had use it or lose it
and i had user to lose it and i lost
some time as probably for the same
reasons i had no problem with that
because that was the agreement
i've also seen
policy manuals that say
you have let's say 10 days vacation
but
uh you have to have worked
a full year
to be eligible for it and it says it
and if you leave in nine months for
whatever reason
then you don't get it
no problem there but if if it says
in
the policy manual
you accumulate one day per month of
vacation let's say
an employer's
obligation to pay a supplier or
or a plumber
i mean it's it literally is an agreement
that the employer makes
do you agree or disagree with my reading
of that um i respectfully disagree
uh thank you mr chairman uh thank you mr
today um maybe um i'm
just trying to slice she's a little
thinner here but and i apologize for
that but
um
following up on the last two questions
then
is it fair to say that you
would uh and none of us are talking
about a gift here we're talking about
the concept of a benefit and its
relationship to compensation
would you say that
absent a specification by
a
an employer that
the
that the employee retains
some interest
in
the value of time off or time off itself
um
the employees
should
always
understand that the nature of the
contract that's been described
does not include any right
to that benefit
in the event
that the employee for reasons beyond his
becomes
unemployed let me answer that in a
couple of different ways
i did testify that i have a lot of
sympathy for employees who through no
fault of their owner no action of their
own
either through a
involuntary layoff that they had no way
of knowing would take place or the sale
of the company that they didn't know
either didn't know it would take place
or didn't understand the impact of it i
have a lot of sympathy
for those employees
this bill goes beyond that to get to
to i think
what the
thrust of your question was
i think that employees
do have
a cause for action or the ability to
make a complaint with the department if
the employer does not live up to what's
written in their benefits policy or
their employee handbook
but
unless
that benefit or employee handbook
specifically states that an employee
will be eligible to be paid
for
earned but unused vacation time
when their employment is terminated
that's not an employee benefit it has to
be stated that it's a benefit you can't
just
i don't believe
you can just assume that that is the
case that's not what the benefit
says and
i suppose
if if this
were something that employees were aware
of or curious about or concerned with
it should come up at the time where
they're discussing the benefit package
representative
thank you mr chairman um mr gervais i'm
looking at uh v-a again
um for the purposes of this paragraph
the terms earn time vacation or vacation
time and paid time off shall be
considered compensation and therefore
constitute wages due
would it satisfy the concerns of the bia
to move that language up into
definitions
uh closer to new section and provide a
more
uh general description of
time that an employee is otherwise
capable of substituting for paid time
but um
respectfully i'd
maybe i think i'd have to look at the
language and and go back to some of our
members that we get guidance from and
ask them so it's hard for me to say yes
or no without
seeing the actual language you're
suggesting
it's still
you know i'm still uncomfortable with
proposals like this that try and spell
out
what employer benefits should be and i
think some of the questions around the
table are illustrating the difficulty in
doing that because there are a lot of
variables that go into a benefit package
there are a lot of differences in terms
that go into benefit packages and it's
and it's hard
i believe to
employee benefit
that
thank you mr german um well i'm looking
at
uh want i
a
uh inform employees in writing of any
policy regarding accrual or medicine i'm
i'm looking at it on the state house
website thank you i just lost you
go ahead i'm sorry thank you mr chairman
um so i am just going to read the
sentence for context um an employer that
no wrong one inform employees of writing
in writing of any policy regarding
accrual or use
of unused earned time and any limits on
why does that line not provide the kind
of flexibility for an employer to be
upfront with employees
ahead of time as to what benefits they
would be able to expect upon separation
outside of the mandate
i'm sorry but were you referring to the
language in the in the bill here
line six of the bill yep i i already uh
testified i don't have a lot of problem
with that language i think that's just
standard good business practice and if
businesses aren't doing that they'll
probably at some point or another have
have an impact associated with that
now
you say no follow-up okay
representative abalone
thank you mr chairman thank you again mr
duvet um lines 12 13 and 14
which will be section two under this
proposal
um
one of your companies has a user to lose
it under vacation time or in time but
they let you bank sick time
to 80 hours
over the life of your employment or up
to 80 hours bank period
under this
if those if that sick time is sitting
there when they're
separated
shall not be considered as wages do they
would lose that time
even though they banked it under the
policy
yeah i can tell you my employer doesn't
allow banking of sick time it's a use it
or lose it the way uh vacation time is
uh but to your question i
my reading of this would be that
employees would not be eligible to be
compensated for that banked time if it
is identified as is sick time or sick
days thank you thank you
welcome
i see no other individuals wishing to
so thank you very much thank you mr
chair
and i was just being jovial guys i
didn't mean to see you you were asking
good questions i wasn't trying to
belittle any of your questions so i
probably shouldn't have said that
representative excuse me bruce burkey
please
i thought i just got to pay cup for a
minute
thank you mr chairman and members of the
house labor committee for your record my
name is bruce berkey
managing partner with she infinity
capital group and one of our client many
of our business clients are concerned
about this bill but specifically
the national federation of independent
business
here in new hampshire over 1400 members
in the state of new hampshire
and as a caveat to one section of the
bill
i would say i don't know specifically
off the top of my head but i would say
that the majority of them have fewer
than 15 employees
however that does not
have me here supporting the bill
nfib is opposed to
for two specific reasons and one general
reason
i'll get to the two specifics first and
and let me also say that uh i've had
conversations with representative cahill
as well they've been very constructive
we have tried to
find that common ground
we're not quite there yet but i will say
that this bill is an improvement over uh
previous year's renditions
with respect to the two specific uh
issues that we have concerns about is um
on line four where it talks about the
that is a concern because any future
legislature could reduce that number
from 15
to 12 to 8
to
whatever that number may might end up
being someday and so it would encompass
even more
businesses and and then with the
negative impacts i'm going to share with
you
and then the second um
specific
concern is down in um
beginning on line 17
where it begins to talk about
the result of a layoff
and
you know
one's
termination
can be good
and once termination can be bad in in
the eye of the beholder as they say
but certainly because the the law is
silent or the proposal is silent and
current law is silent
if i decide to lay off that individual
because they have been embezzling for me
i think that i would have a right to as
an employer to withhold
any extra compensation that might have
been earned through vacation time or pto
so that that's a concern uh for the nfib
members
nfib opposes the bill because it really
is an invasion
of the relationship between the employer
and the employee
and it allows the invasive relationship
to exist
almost for any reason
such as embezzling
um
if the
what needs to be recognized and adhered
to is if the employer
has an employee handbook outlining those
negotiated benefits
whether it be vacation time or pto
and
the employee can be entitled to that
time earned
but without a written policy
an unused vacation time or a pto the
employer needs to have that flexibility
and how that time is treated
laws should not dictate the relationship
between the employee
and the employer
when it comes to this particular area
of the relationship
so
with that i would ask the committee to
find 1514 in expedient to legislate
and i'd be happy to try and address any
questions you may have
any questions for mr burkey
i have one for you
what would your members think and i know
this is tough because just you know do
the best you can in answering it if you
can
what would your uh you think your
members would say if you took the first
lines four through ten
and made those required for employees
with over a hundred employee
well as a b and c
yeah
as mr juve said it's smart to have an
employee handbook any employer
every employer should have one um it's
good for the employee it's good for the
employer
and and so we
would encourage something like that
um
the number 100
certainly better than 15
and
would certainly be preferred over the
current language
thank you
any other questions
somebody how did you
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
taking the question you classified this
bill as a quote invasion of the
relationship between employer and
employee
where would the organization that you
represent draw the line
as to what is considered an invasion and
what isn't and i can provide an example
um
would the organization consider osha
regulations an invasion between
employers in the employer relationship
well thank you representative for the
question um i will say that the nfib
nationally opposed um the osha
regulations when it came to vaccine
mandates for i think it was employers
over 100
and so in general
the nfib does oppose greater and further
regulation where it's not necessary
we've had regulation for many many years
there's no doubt about that
and some of it has come about as a
result of some some very bad experiences
and
so the the business community has
learned to live with those they have
built those regulations into the costs
of what they produce in terms of when
they sell their products
and
the preference will be not to have
further regulations if it can be if it
can be addressed in a matter through an
uh just for clarification prior to the
question uh i wasn't referring to the
vaccine mandate i was referring to osha
regulations more broadly
and i'll throw out another example just
to try to establish where this line is
uh regarding the
description of an invasion uh a
requirement that people get paid for the
time they work
if an employee
determines that an employer would not
pay them for that time worked wouldn't
the free market establish that people
just shouldn't work for that employer
anymore i'm just trying to ascertain
where the line is here because i think
this is something along the lines of
getting paid for the work you've done
sure uh thank you for your question i i
you know i don't think there's a bright
red line uh in any of this
currently there's law laws on the books
with respect to pay
and and i'm sure that
deputy commissioner ogden would be all
over
my members or any employer in the state
of new hampshire if they did not pay the
wages that have been earned
i think in in this instance
this is a
contract moving forward between the
employer and the employee with respect
to the overall package
that an employee signs up for when they
go to work for a particular employer
and that package is is
you know outlined hopefully in a
employee handbook
and that the employee has full knowledge
of
how that relationship for
while they're there and when they decide
to leave
thank you
thank you mr chairman uh thank you mr
berkeys um
as mr duvey has said and you and you
have said um
the expectation is that the um terms of
employment the uh
the uh
guidelines or the manual for employment
we'll be clear on this and obviously we
all would share that view of course in
law most of the
disputes arise from places where
something was left unclarified and the
point
about what
the expectations of the parties then
would
would become a central question to the
extent you can
[Music]
speak
for your membership companies do you
think they would consider
that
a
clarity like this in law
would both reduce
the chance for
litigation and or regulatory
action
and
reduce the
displeasure and
hits to reputation and other
adverse effects from
a
a position taken by companies on this
issue which would run contrary to
reasonable expectations of the employee
thank you representative manaver
yes perhaps a law like this would add
clarity
but i think a law like this would also
have an impact on compensation for
employees down the line
i think that this
by by
by
putting employers into a box
on this
you you lose the flexibility that the
employer has in terms of what they want
what they're going to be able to offer
to that employee
so you know other questions thank you
i say that right
milioto yeah
thank you chairman um so my name is
allison milioto i am the owner and
partner hr consultant for blue lion
we're an hr consulting company based in
new hampshire
we service small to mid-sized businesses
for hr consulting
thank you for your time in allowing me
to speak in opposition of house bill
currently our state is suffering from
labor shortages a mental health crisis
and massive resignation wave employers
are having to work twice as hard to
attract and retain quality employees
employees are able to call the shots
they're requesting well above market
wages and are often receiving them
i believe this proposal proposed
legislation is coming at a time when we
need to be figuring out how to help
employers stay in business and not add
more layers of complex complex
complexity and liability when trying to
make business decisions
if you were to be let go from your job
today how long do you think it would
take to be gainfully employed again and
i'm talking in almost every industry
i would argue less than a week
in this proposed legislation it states
that if an employee gives notice in good
standing they are to be paid all accrued
vacation time
so as a small business owner with 20
employees i now need to try and fill a
position in a labor market that makes
that near impossible while still paying
someone that has made the personal
decision to leave my business
what safety net are we providing
employers for bad employees while we
don't like to make laws for them we do
need to consider them while making
legislation that would benefit them
jane doe can now hop from job to job
just staying long enough to cash in on
her vacation pay
now you may suggest that it's her next
employer due diligence process before
hiring
well unfortunately we're only able to
ask certain questions to her prior
employer
and we've all met jane she's a great
actress
and that's right the only person that
showed up for the interview for this
position the pickings are slim
i want to offer paid time off to be
competitive as an employer
if this legislation passes
do i add a long waiting period to
protect myself
in turn diminishing the benefits for
most
for simplicity and administration and
enhanced benefits to a lot of our client
in and enhanced benefits a lot of our
clients have stopped separating sick
time from vacation time and they just
lump it together as paid time off if
you're never sick great you get a bonus
five days to spend at the beach
having staff take scheduled time off is
easier for a business to manage
most businesses encourage their staff to
take scheduled time off versus sick time
this legislation encourage encourages
employers to split sick time from
vacation time to protect their liability
again decreasing the benefits for most
employees
as a company we would like to allow our
staff to have their time available at
the beginning of the annual period so
that they can take it when it is best
for them and their family this is
commonly called front loaded
with the proposed legislation employers
are going to need to be cautious of
front loading
time for their staff this legislation
encourages them to have it on a cruel
basis
have you ever worked for a company with
an accrual the system and had to tell
your wife that you couldn't go to disney
on february vacation because you have
not yet accrued enough time
again this legislation is encouraging
employers to provide a diminished
benefit for their good employees to
ensure they are protecting themselves
from the liability they cannot control
when a business puts together their
budget for labor for the year it
accounts for someone's annual earnings
the annual amount includes the benefit
of time off if you're here you're paid
to work and if you have your time off
available then you're paid to
stay home
even with this benefit the annual amount
does not exceed that of an annual amount
with this legislation employers now need
to have a line item in their budget for
the liability of all earned time not yet
taken if you quit i now need to pay for
you
pay you for weeks that you are not going
to be working and god willing i have
actually replaced you and also now
paying someone else new to do the same
job
therefore paying in excess the annual
amount i originally budgeted
if we experience a high turnover that
could drastically impact our business
and our budget as a small business
let's look at some industries
specifically how about restaurants
they typically will have more than 15
employees
super competitive industry when it comes
to labor and they want to add great
benefits so they can start attracting
great employees
be careful that one's going to get
expensive
it is proposing this legislation that
the unused vacation time would have to
be paid by the next regular pay cycle
this is a
direct contradiction to rsa 275 44 that
indicates upon termination an employer
has 72 hours to pay all due wages in
full yet again complicating the process
for your employers
so in conclusion i feel that this
legislation will push employers to offer
diminished benefits and reward employees
for changing their place of employment
an employer often cannot control an
employee's decision to leave employment
why should they be rewarded
in closing i also have an additional
question that should be considered how
is this going to affect people that
offer unlimited time policies
it is a very hard it is very hard to
create legislation that is one size fits
all should we not let private employers
determine their policy based on their
business needs industry and labor market
employees have the ability to ask these
questions and know in the hiring process
how their potential employer handles
time off upon termination
in the current landscape and labor pool
to me it doesn't justify a bill of this
measure
and i did just want to add after hearing
the
current legislation
in my understanding and interpretation
in the state of new hampshire if you do
not have a written policy that dictates
what happens to your time off upon
termination whether voluntary or
involuntary you are to be paid for it
so if your company chooses not to write
a policy the state does protect the
employee and you are required to pay it
out i have case instances of clients
that i've supported that have had to pay
out weeks vacation because they did not
have a written policy
i would agree that when you're going
into employment with somebody uh that
you're making an agreement
you are agreeing to terms of your
employment and this is something that
your employer should be dictating do i
feel that you should write policy
requiring them to dictate it no but i
believe that the statute already
protects them should you choose not to
dictate how to play in the sandbox
that there is already legislation
protecting them
if you choose not to dictate how that
thank you
representative you mr chairman
um
i want to follow up on the question that
you asked at the end about companies uh
with unlimited time off statutes how
many companies do you represent that
offer unlimited paid time off
uh off the top of my head i would not
have a number but i would say it is very
industry specific there are certain
industries a lot of tech companies are
going to unlimited time off a lot of
law firms it's the higher white-collared
companies that are typically doing the
unlimited time off follow-up follow-up
just to clarify i'm talking about
unlimited paid time off correct as am i
like you never have to come in
no so policy states that you still do
have to request time off but there is
not a cap on the amount of time it's
usually in industries like you've heard
from several gentlemen today that always
lose time it's the industries where
people are not taking the time they're
provided so rather than telling you you
get to take five weeks but you only ever
take three we tell you take however much
time you ever want those industries
typically are not taking time off that
your dedicated workers that are working
50 to 60 hours a week they're not taking
time off follow up
thank you mr chairman uh you talked
about um this creating a burden on
employers to
uh have to pay these benefits out how
many minutes would it take for
an employer that you represent uh to sit
down and uh do the cash out option for
these benefits where this lot of pass
can you rephrase the question
you're asking me how much time it takes
the time to cut a check would be
probably less than five minutes thank
you
thank you mr chairman um
for some of us who've only worked for
larger firms and that's all we're
familiar with you made some statements
that
uh
might be a little confusing you kind of
differentiated between
the cost of paying a long time employee
well they take a couple of weeks off and
you shuffle the schedule
to account for that
and the cost of paying people who don't
work for you anymore and that that's a
the pay rate for two weeks
you implied those are very different
situations
on the employer's books could you help
some of us understand absolutely thank
you for the question and i'd love to
clarify so i was describing um you work
for me i've allocated 50 000 a year for
your salary so you're going to work 48
weeks and i'm gonna pay you for four
weeks to be off but i'm still paying you
fifty thousand dollars for the year
you leave halfway through i now need to
pay you out the four weeks of time but
i've also replaced you
so i'm now in the rears of four weeks
that i've had to pay you in excess
because i've filled your position so
while i allocated fifty thousand dollars
for that position for the year i've now
gone over by let's call it four thousand
dollars in my budget because i'm paying
you not to be here but yet i've now
hired representative callum to take your
place so i'm paying him to actually work
while you're getting paid
and i would like to also add for small
businesses to come up with that kind of
money
on a consistent basis and have that
liability on their books that you could
choose to leave at any time and i can't
control that
to then carry that weight is is a big
burden for a lot of small business
owners
thank you mr chairman i'd like to thank
you for your testimony is very succinct
and articulate and can we get a copy of
it
could the chairman get it and give it to
the committee we'll do so thank you and
a follow-up question yes
could you explain
a little bit more in detail between a
front load and then an accrual basis it
might have
confused a few people yeah thank you for
the question and i do realize after
sitting through the earlier testimonies
and questions um that that might be
addressed partially in the verbiage
where it says that it would be prorated
which i do agree is this a very vague
statement so front loading someone's
time off let's say everyone gets their
time on january 1st everyone gets a
refresh companies that front load on
january 1st you would get your full
annual amount in your bank of pto so if
you're four weeks in the year you get
four weeks available on january 1st to
do what you would like if you're an
accrual basis they take the four weeks
and they divide it amongst all your pay
periods so each week when you work you
accrue a little bit of time so therefore
it takes time for you to build up a bank
commonly we do see with clients that
offer an accrual system uh that they do
allow carryovers so everyone's not
starting at zero on january they do
often accompany an accrual
policy with
thank you mr chairman thank you for the
follow-up um
so a employer who front loads and then
an employee takes all their time and
then february 1 says hey i'm quitting
how does the employer recoup that
four weeks vacation pay under this law
thank you for your question uh that's
actually a
reason that a lot of employers will go
to an accrual system there is no current
legislation that protects an employer uh
there is no amount due it's not an iou
and this legislation doesn't address
that concern at all so it
i don't want to say it's one-sided but
it is a little one-sided in that uh
there is no protection again for the
employer if you choose to take all of
your vacation which does happen we we
commonly suggest that our clients do the
accrual base for that reason
so you're not overpaying before the
welcome representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
testimony
i may have misunderstood it though and i
just want to be sure i am understanding
it correctly i thought you had said that
say in the instance of a company with
20 employees and they have a employee
manual and it says
you'll accrue
a
one-week
vacation
period for each year you work up to a
maximum of five
and so you've worked as an employee for
this company for
um 15 or 20 years or something and
there's a layoff
that came out of the blue because of
market conditions or whatever it was
and
you have
uh not taken any of your it's it's
almost the end of the year and you
haven't taken any vacation
um
is it
is it your testimony that under current
law or
regulation that that
employer under those circumstances has
to compensate
the employee for
the value of that
unused vacation time
yes thank you for your question uh so my
testimony states that if there is not a
policy written so if you have a policy
that states that it is forfeited then it
would be forfeited but if you do not
have so in the absence of a policy
current legislation states that the
employee is entitled to the payout
follow up
follow up thank you uh yes thank you i
that part i got i i was posing the
question with the ambiguity that the
policy just said what i said it said
that
um
you're entitled to these
uh five weeks
it doesn't say what happens
if
the company if you get laid off it just
there's nothing in the
um
the guidelines that say you you get
credit for it or you lose it
we don't know
in that instance would you agree with
mr berkey and mr duvet that
the employee is not entitled to any
compensation of any type for that loss
no i would not so currently my
understanding of the legislation is in
the absence of the policy that states
what happens upon termination so a
layoff an acquisition a merger they're
all terminations the prior employer
terminates the new employer hires
so that termination if they did not have
a policy that stated what happens upon
termination whether voluntary or
involuntary they would be entitled to be
so you know other questions thank you
very much
um i i like to look at body language and
i see some body language from rudy ogden
i'm going to call him up later and i
think he has a few things to say so if
you mind if i just let our last speaker
then you can come back up rudy
gary abbott
mr abbott thank you chairman committee
members for the record my name's gary
abbott i'm the executive vice president
of the associated general contractors of
new hampshire
i almost want to listen to rudy's
testimony before mine
[Music]
we're here in opposition i want to i
think the speakers before me gave a
pretty good uh
discussion of the
of the bill but every time i hear a bill
of earned time i'm going to tell you
what flags it for us
it's the word earned
and then in this bill which people
really haven't talked about is line 12
13 and 14.
i really highlighted
what constitutes wages do
this puts in place something very unique
in the statute
whether it's for 15 employees or more or
whatever it's constituting a benefit is
wages
and i agree with dave duvet who spoke
earlier
most companies started vacation sick pay
for employees to take it while they work
we want people to take time off so
they're good employees over the whole
course of working for a company
this this earned part and i want to
describe my understanding of the law i'm
glad you're going to have rudy after me
but my understanding of the law
and most of the companies i represent i
would almost guarantee they have
company office policies that address
these type of things
what you would be compensated when you
leave how your 401k program works all of
these things
are in company office policies
i agree there may be some
if a company closes some of the examples
it might not be in there because
companies base their office policies
that they're in business this is how
it's going to work whether you terminate
or not
but it's the word earned and it's it's
it's been in all of these bills where
you earn 10 hours a month or whatever
you know that the word earned
for me it's been a benchmark of how
company allocates vacation time not
necessarily it's earned as compensation
and that's the
the disconnect is that
you could have a company that you get
paid your vacation time if you meant if
you meet other qualifications within
your office policies
like you leave us in good standings but
good standings in the office policy
could be you give us two weeks notice
and if you don't give us two weeks
notice you don't get that that amount
companies vary their policies not all
companies do that
some companies have other regulations
and other decisions based on their own
company
there's no one size fits all and i think
that becomes the problem but if you i
also heard discussions on the first
section the first section to me almost
reads like current law
an employer has to do his office
policies gives it to the employee and if
you break those regulations with your
employee
rudy's coming after you
that's what's going to happen that is
you have it in writing you're giving it
to the employee you have to meet that
all the companies understand that so i'm
looking at the top part that's really
what a company does with their hr
professionals and how the company works
so i don't i understand why people are
not having a big problem with that
section because that's what ninety
percent of the companies are doing
but the the next part of constitute
wages constitute wages what the
department of labor will come in and do
is if they have an employee that says
hey i don't think i got paid the
appropriate wages they'll come into the
company and want to see those office
policies are you living within your
office policies that's really what
they're going to look at
and that's going to be the determining
factor
so we've worked with this system for
years this is how it's worked
prior to legislation
and companies really know they've got to
spell out how it works
maybe you have this 10 hours per day but
you're only eligible for two weeks if
you leave you know there's all kinds of
different it doesn't mean you earn it
for a little 10 years you're going to be
compensated for it because it as you
heard in previous testimony the
liability of the amount it is a
liability fair or an accountant you
would know at the end of the year for
some of these companies it's a audited
liability tax amount if a company policy
does pay it out
one of the scary parts of this bill is
you may have a lot of companies now i'm
confused at the bill
if we write a policy
but i read uh slide 17
va
it says who leaves in good standings
should there be additional language in
good standings according to your company
policy are we talking that
or good standing that you work for me
but it the policy doesn't come into
effect i'm a little gray because policy
what the company has and how that's
interpreted what good standing is
and that's where some of these other the
company policy says
you got to leave in good standing but
you got to give us a proper notice so we
can hire another person whatever that
policy is
i'm not saying everybody's company
policy is like that but different
companies are different some have used
it or lose it
the scary the scariest part is
if you put this in
what happens with all these companies
and they just say
there is no wages earned or compensated
and this is where this line 13
if you have a policy in which
many companies don't pay out sick leave
but some do some do but say you now
adopt that as your vacation time
period we give you four weeks a year but
we decide
in the policy you don't get paid for any
vacation time i don't think you want to
go in that direction i think companies
still want to pay as a benefit
but this sets up some very questionable
things so
we like the system that currently is in
place now if you were going to draft a
bill to address
company buyouts i get it that's not
normally in a company policy
it's not in there may need to be
language that makes it clear
what happens at the labor department
when they do that
i think those kind of situations are
unique
but this bill addresses all companies
that are 15 or more
so those are our concerns which put us
in place to
at this time oppose the legislation
because
we think the system that currently is in
place works
i thank the uh committee for listening
thank you mr chairman um just one
question
you lay one of your few of your
companies lay off for the season
would that be considered termination and
would you be on the hook if you brought
them back for all their vacation time up
to that point or do you roll that over
into when they come back because it is a
seasonal job
and i think that that varies a lot um
because we have seasonal layoffs
um i know some of the companies are very
generous that even during the seasonal
layoff they pay health insurance and
they do some other things
that
because they're coming back
they may have policies regarding within
their own company
how they handle
vacation time and sick time
and it may be choices but i don't know
those situations but i'm sure they've
worked it out
what's best for keep retaining those
employees so
this bill you're absolutely right
it could affect it because now if they
have to pay out where they before were
saying
you know you can come back but i also
think
unemployment office which is over my
other shoulder
you know they have very specific regs
that how much money if they are paying
out vacation before you start
unemployment so there's
there's other stipulations but i don't
want to get into the two agency rules
we've got two experts in the room here
behind me and i would leave it to them
but
this if you're trying to address certain
specific issues maybe that would be the
so you know other hands thank you thank
you
i'd like to call uh
the only reason i call you uh is i saw
you shaking your head you disagreed with
something that was uh being presented
yes i wanted you to be able to so thank
you chairman infantine and just for the
record rudy ogden department of labor uh
one of the members was asking me so the
one point uh and i really might very
much appreciate the uh testimony and
perspective offered by those uh before
me just in terms of existing legislation
and how we would handle a situation in
which there's not defined policy 275 43
5 says that it's employment practice or
policy or both
so i just want to be clear that if we
did not have a policy on the books and
to how such time was handled by such
time i mean earn time vacation time or
such things as that we would be looking
at what the employer's practice is so i
just want to be clear that presently as
as we're administering the law and i
will speak with the testimony afterwards
i'm just wondering where that came from
and hoping it's not coming from us i'm
hoping a question didn't come to us and
we answered it that way but existing law
would be that we would look at then the
employer's practice so again mindful of
everyone's time but i just wanted to
you guys can talk about that offline
representative
thank you very much uh mr chairman and
since i have you back here i have kind
of a legal question
um the term layoff has been used a lot
here and i remember many years ago an hr
representative
kind of telling us quit calling this a
layoff it's a reduction in force and i'm
wondering if a term like layoff has
in terms of
so my understanding different state
entirely different circumstances but a
layoff was when you suspended the
position with the intent on bringing it
back
doesn't would new hampshire look at that
term as legally loaded or
can we use it in kind of the
well i would say
thank you for the question
representative for our purposes in
administering rsa 275 or the other
chapters under our title we would be
looking at how it is addressed within
that statute or that particular section
if it's not addressed and it's just
generally put out there as layoff we
would then be looking at okay what's the
generally understood term of that
so there's not particular legal meaning
in the sense that typically when we
looked for particular legal meaning
we're looking for that section how is it
defined within that section or within
that chapter or within that title so
again we would kind of go from there in
the absence of a specific definition
there we'd be going to just how is that
thank you mr chairman
if it's not
too complicated question how is it
generally understood again for us it
would be a layoff is in some ways looked
at as a i i would want to think about it
a little bit more but uh we see a layoff
as different than termination for cause
or termination for a specific reason
layoffs are usually
lack of work
lack of financial resources to do it
again i'd want to think about it a bit
more but
that's where i would start
thank you president
thank you mr chairman thank you deputy
commissioner
lines 12 13 and 14
are a sticking point
for a few of the presenters and myself
are we redefining compensation and wages
due based upon a benefit
you are in the sense that existing law
would say they they are considered due
uh
based upon what policy or practice is so
right now as speakers before me have
said
compensation is being defined
relative to this annual or earned time
by when the employer says it's earned
therefore it is wages this would be
changing it to say
specifically when it is
accrued or
bestowed in the sense of a front loading
scenario that it it is by that point
you know questions thank you very much
for coming up again is there anyone else
who would like to speak on this bill
i have no no one else scheduled
all right being that i'm an hour behind
um i'm going to close this hearing i
have to unfortunately leave unexpectedly
um vice chairman is going to take over
the final bill um
and just give me a second to get out of
here
all right it
seems to have settled down so i will
open up the hearing on hb
1569 and ask the prime sponsor to
introduce the bill
um thank you mr chairman and thank you
members of the labor committee um at the
time of bill drafting i was seeing
things happening in other parts of the
country where workers were not laid off
but were barred from entering their
workplace so that they constructively
couldn't were fired but couldn't get
unemployment we never saw that happen
here our laws already cover the
situation in new hampshire so the first
section of the bill in my view is
unnecessary the second section came to
my attention as a colonel in the
reserves spoke to a lot of spoke to a
lot of issues that he had and he had
found with retention because of uh
the name of it the the drill pay
but that actually is already in law that
that's not wages
so i seem to have brought a bill to you
that is completely unnecessary so i
would ask that uitl it
are there any questions for the
representative
probably shouldn't do this but
um i i did get an email i believe
yesterday um from
a colonel in the um national guard who
was asking us to address this issue on
his behalf um is he now aware that this
is in the statute and because it sounds
like he actually was harmed by
the situation is he now satisfied and
going to get his back pay
actually he is the one who brought it to
my attention initially so thank you for
that important question he actually told
me that it was in law i assume somebody
on this committee informed him of that
and so once he was informed that it was
covered he's now pivoting to making sure
that everybody within the reserves is
aware that those are not wages and that
they do qualify for unemployment even if
they are drilling once a month
thank you
any further questions
seeing none thank you very much
i also have a card from deputy
commissioner lavers
um
i think
we've we've been given the suggestion
that we simply itl if you can quickly
shed some light on
what's already in the law i think that
and turn on
is that better
for the record richard lavers deputy
commissioner new hampshire department of
employment security
so the department doesn't have a
position
on this bill uh the first component of
the bill would would
uh seek to define uh or broaden the
what's considered as totally unemployed
so someone that is unable to access
their place of employment and the second
component would
exclude from what is considered wages
when you're collecting unemployment and
what needs to be deducted from your
unemployment benefit
just to clarify that
those types of
wages if earned while you're collecting
unemployment still need to be reported
to the department
we ask a series of questions on your
weekly claim regarding any work or any
earnings that you did have individuals
still need to report that to the
department it's not the individual who
decides what gets reported and doesn't
that needs to be reported the department
determines whether or not is something
that is excludable or is going to be
applied against your unemployment
benefit
all right thank you
are there questions for the commissioner
i see representative avilani
thank you mr chairman not to drag this
out but um
some of the drill stuff is that
um i would have to defer to um
how it is actually paid to the national
guard
earnings that are being paid while
you're collecting unemployment
it falls within the scope of what needs
to be reported
now there are many different types of of
pay as i understand it
that is received based upon the
type of mission on which someone is
working or if it's not considered as a
mission
employment security
um
benefited tremendously from the work of
the men and women of the national guard
during the pandemic
and they were a lifesaver to us for
everything that they did but i believe
that
that type of pay still needs to be
reported to us if you are filing for
unemployment
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
thank you very much for coming before us
i
don't have any other cards
and seeing no one else who wishes to
speak i'll close the hearing on 1569.
that is our final public hearing for
today
um
can you ask him a question
can you ask him offline since
we've technically closed that here
uh so i don't know if everyone here is
aware we had originally
planned to have an executive session
this afternoon
uh with the absence i know the chairman
discussed it with some people we are not
going to hold that executive session
um as the chairman said he is trying to
arrange the substitute days and that
will have to be worked through
um
the
availability of facilities
right now he was talking about the
second which is a wednesday
um maybe trying to do
some of our executive session then and
then finishing on
on the 10th of march
which is a thursday
and i think our final day to do any
execs but
that has to be scheduled so look for the
and if there
looks like everybody's leaving so
there are no other questions
you